all right and we are live welcome to the
islands podcast and the Lords of gaming
dotnet episode number 114 this is
another glorious Sunday we're back at
the roundtable on the Lord's Day and
happy patriarch snake salute to all the
wonderful fathers out there in the room
you are appreciated and respected the
majority of Lords have returned from our
West Coast trip and we have the e3 2019
aftermath series with two very special
guests so we go get right into it I want
to introduce the Lord who in my opinion
is the epitome of true gamer passion
combined with the blueprint of
journalistic integrity this Lord
exemplifies professionalism on every
article he does yet at the same time
doesn't take himself too seriously
with his vintage wit and trademark humor
introducing the editor for Windows
central.com and co-host of the xbox two
podcasts fellow ex-con Fame fellow
division to fame and the Lord who
correctly changed it to it a handle to
2077 for the game at a generation that's
cyberpunk laugh from Germany and making
his return into the realm of the Lords
mommy Lord just Gordon how you doing sir
I'm your intros a legendary so much I'm
Ron's intros this guy's making me feel
special running around man how has
things settled down for you a little bit
oh god yeah the last few weeks have been
hectic as hell and now it's like no e3
is over I'm just like just chilling and
then I'm going on vacation
nice yeah I need a drink to a man about
a week or two you just need a mental
break cuz it's like you're running
around you're doing so much there's so
much information and yeah so you're out
there man you had a lot to talk about it
so that's good no doubt and of course we
have a lord who has given us 1 million
reasons as
why he sits on the Xbox iron throne
whether it be his balance appearance on
ladies gaming news or his clear concise
presentation and delivering it this Lord
should easily be in everyone's top five
list
introducing the creator and host of the
rand outdoor youtube channel and co-host
of the xbox to podcasts mister saw serve
himself and the lord of crushing fake
xbox rumors so we don't get to guests
yet affront alert love from the south
side of the shop and making his return
into the realm of the lord's mommy Lord
Randolph Thor 19 how you doing sir what
is going up
cockney bill you make me feel so special
more so than just ever
hi I am NOT 1 I'm I'm I speak to jazz
every day but we even actually spoke and
spoken since last time we did a podcast
the week was at the Thursday before that
we already know and of course you know
we got the Four Horsemen of gaming those
original Lords here at the round table
my calls with the co most my brother
from another mother
the difficult game khakhra and the heart
of the goal for mommy
with the breaking beer Lord at all right
thanking beer you know to be fair they
can't see my beard
so there you go alert now
playing Italian goes dead doesn't matter
he's never gonna go dead sir because I
got it charge was good I had been pretty
pretty good you know so finally
recovered from jet lag like that that's
real that's a real thing like the past
two days I've been like on autopilot
just waiting to sleep
mmm trust me I know to feel I'm still in
recovery well the service is still
settled in you're almost back to normal
yeah yeah I finally got a good amount of
sleep last night
mm-hmm good that's what's up that's
what's up and of course we have our most
technical gaming Lord the solo gamer who
lives for the single player selfish
experience and also the sastra Damas mr.
offline profile Illuminati and lore
patron of the I bake mommy
Lord Denzel sovereign now exit still
under the table you extra lately so like
he got a little intoxicated that first
night then we went to the Bethesda thing
like he took one sip was like I'm going
home down cuz addict you forget we was
at the homes at the time urban spot
I was going in doing them drinks
presenting this everybody's asleep and
King is is wide awake at 1:00 in the
morning
I never told y'all so when the Sun go
down the King come out I was done you
know my old man came out but have you
settled in sir I mean as much as
possible I mean again tonight tomorrow
go back to 4:00 in the morning so we'll
see how I do so it shout out to lower
boom stick stick Excel and our friends
over at pepto-bismol for holding me down
shout out to them no doubt and of course
we have the Incredible Hulk of this aka
the excess gamer mm-hmm
Lord of combat sports king of the
statues who demands nothing less than
that premium experience it is the leader
of the fraud alert movement mmm beloved
Lord King Lord Corvette kid go we didn't
get a chance to see that hamburger get
eaten by uh
Tyson Fury you know he felt all good
because he put on 25 extra pounds um
some fish he should be doing that let me
know that you didn't take that fight
truly seriously and nor should you
you know I'm you're not Anthony Joshua
so you're not gonna get rolled up by a
tomato can um that fight like I said was
oh boy was a hamburger and he deserved
to get eaten got his lunch eight in the
second round it was absolute garbage
fight it was so terrible that ESPN
should be ashamed give a shout-out to
Delilah HD Delilah thank you our video
that you shot of me using X cloud is
that twenty five thousand views so uh I
do appreciate you are being right there
and holding it down and you bear witness
to the facts that a lot of these frauds
out here running with some different
narrative deal with the frauds early on
next product over a bit I shouted a lot
of excuses out there holding it down
yeah your main was out there test for
you looking like Apollo Creed out
delivered in America except anybody
anybody cast a Senior Circuit and
some backwoods place you know top of the
top you already know mojito and of
course we have the Lord of the
cooperative experience and gaming ninja
himself
this shouldn't ob Lord 2077 kognito
right now we are we going they're going
to believe now you know just just just
hear me out I'm starting to believe that
like you know that that cyberpunk 77
that's not even really a game it's just
a way to make people who don't home yeah
you've been hit you with the pepper
spray they knock yeah you wake up in
like a little like a little chair they
have I like to refer to the game as Deus
Ex Excel Oh don't mean you ain't a car I
will not talk to the uneducated tell me
about it like next to me that's not even
that's not even cyberpunk that stay
exact that's the next one the beta CD
Projekt RED is using it to build an army
to take over the world not telling you
what you want to hear but what you need
to hear you need to hear that you know
you might need a little bit of help we
might need to get you into some kind of
role-playing eat it but um yo shut out
not much game and obviously exams
running around but um shout out to all
my buddies on a switch our fandom drop
doctrine on came out creative forge
games it's kind of been a rough
situation from that studio um they've
gone through some turmoil
Phin actually like one of the leaders I
interviewed he's no longer there he was
promoted to CFO but left it so it's just
a message that this creative force teams
that is it's known is that the same but
shout out to the team because phantom
doctrine is a cult classic it finally
came out on a switch and it's for XCOM
lovers for espionage lovers I highly
recommend it I played like six hours
straight all my flights going and coming
back such a good game and I said what a
shot those guys out cuz still the game
was good but that was that for me but I
won't do some one little different like
we normally do all moms who yours do the
game stuff and all that but for those
who attended III you know saying I just
want to go over real quickly do the Lord
to just shout out some experiences like
just on any special memory moment
moments or like I may be the person you
want to shout out it made nature III
experience I want to start with jazz you
were there and your little special
moments any shoutouts you want to give
your your experience man so many I mean
there was so many ago I it's when you
met me Eddie
oh but seriously like there's so many
like just awesome people came up to say
hi and you know from from the industry
and from the farm fest to and stuff like
that you know I think that that's what
made it for me like forget the games
it was obviously but it's like you know
you really do get a sense of community
when you go to e3 like across the whole
industry like people who go every year
you know stuff like that said it's kind
of like a tradition at this point it's a
little bit different for Jess because
like you know he literally does it for a
living but like for us it's like you
know obviously we go there for IOP but
you know it's kind of been a tradition
even if we wasn't an ILP we would still
probably be going so yeah I'm still here
and keeps breaking my heart every year I
don't I don't get to see his
breathtaking side one day Rand one day I
was there man 2016 oh it was fun I
really didn't know you like I do offer
you but I did
I'll force round to go in 2020 how you
gonna force you're gonna get a plane
over there just like dude he's pretty a
big person to Leakey's nudes no I can't
oh man it was good thank you for the $10
super check you're all breathtaking
salute the iron Lords and xbox two
chairs from Germany thank thank you
brother
tweet yesterday about that also shout
out the medicine you know you know what
he you know shout out to us and cheers
pandering you know what he's all - King
I'm starting to think cyber punks in
Germany man oh experiences let's get
Lord a decree any shoutouts any
memorable moments on your HP trip well
I've been watching boogie2988 five six
years I finally got to meet that dude um
I saw a really really nice Tiffa cosplay
not to mention man dad so you know how
you play situations
I'm actually really nice cloud cosplay -
yeah actually a shout out the a and
Final Fantasy guys they had a great long
yeah I got I got pushed out a line so I
missed out on playing Final Fantasy 7 so
you know they gotta bring that up to me
anything else what I was pretty much as
far as any little memorable joints I got
to see a lot of funny King Twitter video
thumbs yes yes King was little to it for
show for sure especially especially that
word Kratos he was though oh yeah about
Kratos yeah you know whatever mumbling I
did it ever mom leo
[Music]
no diet okay they kept like rotating
around each other like they were like it
was classic I love that those up no
doubt Lord sovereign back at e3 this
year you know it's good we missed you
took a year off yeah man what how's it
what was your some experience for your
just any memorable moments or shadows
just the most fun like seeing seeing
everybody at the house you know me Lord
Lord since tur we haven't seen for a
long time Lord goes just like just that
camaraderie even though like because
some people in fan fest some people are
not like our schedules are different and
we didn't get to hang out as much we'd
like to but still just that that
camaraderie in the house was cool and
then just sort of being part of
everything that you guys know no one
went missing this year oh man I got I
got it I got to give a shout out to a to
boomstick he know he did like I give a
shout out to but just being a part of
what you guys have been a part of all
these years you know I got to meet
people that you guys have known for
years so I felt a little more included
this year yeah and hopefully you know
maybe it's the first year I went
everybody was sort of doing their own
thing as well and it just it what didn't
feel like the experiences that you guys
have been talking about since you all
had been in fan fest or whatnot so just
to get a little more of a taste of that
was fun um but when it comes to the game
honestly when you're walking around the
show floor trying to you know just get
covers and stuff like that the least
thing you're interested in is playing
which is weird but it's true like I
don't really if I can get my hands on
something without too much hassle cool
beyond that I think I played three games
at e3 I played I played bleeding-edge
and I played X cloud that's gonna click
okay I play Halo 5 off X cloud I play
bleeding-edge and I played attack on
humans that's destroy humans that's
literally all that's right I forgot
about that
AHQ notic that was I know my food that
was did she's kind of like the gracious
gracious exactly that was fun
no doubt no doubt Lord King back at e3
in tremendous tau and Celebi nearby my
any memorable experiences or shout out
sir
okay um I'm not gonna shout out anybody
because it's it's way too many people to
actually shout out so all the people
that I actually dam or I actually talk
to or I actually followed that I got a
chance to meet its it was ridiculous um
I do I do want to say for one person
though Erik's oh yeah and you know um
when I saw him what threw me off is in
his videos and stuff like that he looks
shorter yes
oh boy is my height all right and um and
he showed me because I was talking about
monkey and he told me that that threw me
off completely um but other than that I
listen everybody equally we had such a
great time I do want to give a lot of
frauds out to a lot of fruits I'm gonna
give a lot louder to do frauds because I
sent you the address
it said the doors open you if I sent you
a damn and you got the door was open it
was a goal for you you it was a good
goal we had there you know did you kuzey
the hot tub the arcade games alcohol was
on deck it was crazy
yes and the sad fact is you Hollywood me
know but I do know this though once you
saw I was out in Calabasas yeah one of
those people
uh-huh he was already at the house shut
up oh yeah and we had a memorable
situation where I had to throw somebody
in the actual bushes those who know
about the stories that easily Oh same
stories at 8 we what was seen
um sir it was it was such a great thing
you get the past oh you get the past and
Megatron because you put that rooftop
party together
you got the turn on your part I do and
the drinks was flowing shout out to
Megatron for you ruin his III or yearly
jump off that was so late everybody
needs to know that he is the man that
knows the men and knows the man it is
the man and he keeps everybody together
so really appreciate you brother like I
said we get that invite you know the
Lord's rode through yeah I got a lot but
I try to go to as fast as possible for
myself but um first of all you're like
sobs a shout out the boom steak excel at
true-blue that's my brother right there
great to work alongside him his work at
this second to none
it's just someone as crazy as me up in
the night with ideas and stuff and
that's my best my dumela users requested
over into the house
listen bruh we got the guest house all
right type of level today as a VIP
velvet ropes or not repair those
shattered Akali crew you know they
require your boat I was love shot the
Mokka man I ran into him a few times man
and I actually jumped on a podcast I was
doing live with uh with brat which is
kind of funny and then a true friend to
the realm the great bail scale Oh back a
lot of stuff we'll talk about mr. X
cloud a lot of love shout the season
gaming nasally vote in the birth signs
finally get yeah that was dope you know
I'm saying the whole one away bloody
cake a mega
gwg grown woman gaming they was out
there yeah yeah native in the flesh
Samba Tovar so I'm gonna rope and shout
the PlayStation bruh bumped him a few
times
I got a shoutout Bungie Kotaku
was ill soft but what oh yeah Jason's
try Stephen Hotel oh thanks for my love
yeah yeah
legendary dude who we ignored the whole
I was a funny stubble with time like we
literally just chopping it up wish ride
indeed just and the funny thing is like
we didn't round our whole thing like
they were walking across like before you
know got the pack there with the best
whiskey on deck euros it I was good and
of course love Matt piscatella I met
Daniel dry for the first time which was
kind of cool good do got a chance any
lasting anybody who pulled up you're
saying like any of the Lord's travels
like anybody like hip-hop game ready for
me and super easy super G oh boy why the
home young developer on n64 Josh you
know saying oh man and the last thing
I'm gonna say I know we're going to talk
too much about games but on I just wanna
give up so a couple studios um that
really like every year but this year
especially CD Projekt RED we will get
into it oh my lord
warhorse my man Toby there just to see I
miss you bro it was late miss tremendous
love and I got a shower addict out man
ninja Tyrael I like that cruel I like
that crew really fun sucker
yeah real passionate about the Ronnie
you know I'm saying that she was struck
tremendous and I'll solve you know we
got rebellion studios were yeah they
looked out Oh excellent we don't take
any footage from in there but these guys
really gave us the the red carpet
treatment
genius - looks amazing I didn't get to
see Sambi armor but I've seen of it
looks very cool yeah sure they killed it
I shot the Pete Fisher
you know tremendous got a lot of passion
for gaming this year even more so like
you said he would used to know that but
that's all we got so we get it to the
show we got a lot to recap a lot to
discuss I'm gonna switch it up we all
know a lot of you waiting for the main
event that is Microsoft we're gonna fly
through the others first those there
real quick so for those who actually
either attended or watched these
conferences we're gonna start off with
the PC gaming show did who watch who
didn't watch I find out who didn't watch
or the PC gaming show it all
so me okay who's the also-ran you from
me Brandon he actually owns that mic as
I said to my boss like can we not get
this information Andrew bago we own them
yeah maybe we should look into that I
didn't even watch it though oh you
always - wait so Jezza rental boat oh
I'll set it off who's me
Iraq actually attic and King I didn't
make it kingi didn't make it either no
no no way cuz I didn't make and for some
reason they reserved way in the building
it looks like this is me and solved then
yes basic Oh real quick your impressions
of said PC game show um I think this
year was a little weirder than past
years like in terms of the organisation
it didn't seem as organized as before
obviously the like the host I forget his
name but he's we disrespect show but it
was it just it just felt a little more
disorganized there were moments like
they were doing presentations from from
up on top but then it wasn't being
forecast
it wasn't being broadcast on the on the
screen so if you're down below
you're not seeing anything that's going
on upstairs so it was weird I don't know
if they had some technical issues but
overall it just seemed like a lot of the
PC games that were showing were very
cool smaller games things that you know
a very PC centric and obviously but it
just didn't have that wow factor that
other ones did where you had certain you
know announcements that you maybe didn't
expect that the PC gaming show like
obviously we did miss the last 30
minutes because we had to go get ready
for Ubisoft so we left um but I just
felt overall it just didn't feel it
didn't it didn't feel as great as as
past years I'm obviously you know a lot
of announcements with the epic game
store you know
shout out you know obviously you know
seeing um Shenmue going to the edge
legend uses uki the best Luke in the
building things
that were cool but overall favorite
company they retweet Natick now oh my oh
my lord yes continue I mean again it was
it was kind of man it was kind of man
yeah I'll double down I mean I'll make
this quick look nothing really moved me
to her and the thing about I saw it
low-key PC Gamer sure will usually be
one of my favorite conferences like they
always we sure and again I got a shout
out on my bleep name Sean Plott actually
okay a day nine here's one of the best
conference holes I'm tell you right now
if you've never seen this man man can
host a press conference he is a beast
he's a wizard taking notes man this guy
is a beast and it's just like I don't
know it just nothing really moved me and
then one thing I okay when it comes to
gameplay PC game conference is the best
you get basically all games late you're
not getting any CGI trailer as you're
getting game play up and down yeah
absolutely and I think what it is is
just that I think I was kind of on an
attic train I thought epic was gonna
show out more hard with exclusives and I
didn't really get that vibe because
obviously they were hosting the PC
gaming shows and I was that and then
yeah Shenmue 3 I'm biased but I gotta
keep it even though you Suzuki's my
gaming hero and all this other stuff
it's just the whole epic story
controversy ruined it yeah and it's like
to be honest is like I got to keep a run
you know I'm Schemmel to the core but
the faces don't expect anything but what
you saw there oh the stur lip-syncing
often like it's it's one of those so bad
it's good like it's one of those as bad
as bad but it's you know it's old-school
channel 5 I look like somebody got
finessed at the door it looked like they
took you checked your pilot spot what a
lot of people were saying right a lot of
people wanted their money back from the
Kickstarter was an epic story exclusive
yeah yeah you know what
that's exactly how people felt after
they saw X cloud
oh he wanted their money back so that's
what I got up Lord saw what was your PC
gaming um a through ranking I gave it
honestly just because I the lack of the
wow factor
III give it a c-minus cuz the content
was there it just wasn't for whatever
reason it didn't pop like that like
previous years for me and a few
technical you know missteps and stuff
like that beat but beyond that I mean
the content was there so I give it a
seat yeah I'm gonna have to give it a do
y'all like it at all didn't like it at
all guy what's a question addict I
didn't watch that obviously because they
wouldn't let me in so look it's exciting
yeah yes it would be I gotta look up
some reactions after the park yes
actually it's very it's a big
controversy because yes I love it lying
to stay wait hold on and not giving
refunds and people are pissed like all
about that epic store smoke so um yeah
Maddie for me I just like I said just a
little disappointed cuz again I usually
get excited for that show wasn't up to
expectation well hopefully they will
bounce back we will move on to the next
conference um Square Enix Oh Big C
Square Enix it was Cognito favorite one
don't get it we're getting o rant in
Lord Jack did you guys bow CR Square
Enix I was yeah ten but okay I watch we
may get that make me your plus one a
nothing that did plus ones but they did
a lot of minuses so being that Lord Rand
of our guest has seen it let's talk
Square Enix conference impressions and
then you're a through F ranking my FC I
don't know anything down for squares so
let's go off a memory I think they start
did I start what's Final Fantasy 7
remake
yeah pretty much it was it was really
good because you wanna know what
gameplay demo yeah you gotta be three
who would have thought Rain Man
all right I feel like that's a shot by
oh no I'm starting to see the narrative
right now you know boys loading this
clip let's go get it ready let's get to
it um
Final Fantasy seven is one of my
favorite games of all time okay maybe a
little bit however I don't like the idea
that it's episodic I don't like that
it's basically what two discs of content
for the first five percent of the game
like what are they actually going to
finish the rest of the game Square come
out openly and said when this game the
first one's gonna end which is like it's
not even that's not even half of well I
mean did they did they come out and say
it's just Midgard yes they've come on
said the first game is I look for beats
I looked I couldn't no he said it he
said it was there so that makes I it
took them this long just to do Midgar I
don't know how long we're gonna be
waiting for her you know
remake - and remakes or how many remakes
earlier than negative you know I think
I'm like I'm like round right one of my
favorite games of all time yes not my
favorite game upon him and as such I
find it hard to get excited for this
even though I looked super sleek and
super sleek all I can think about is
what are they gonna cut out of this how
long is the next part when's the next
part coming out like 2025 or something
like it's hard to get excited knowing
that they could butcher butcher it
completely like just make it like a
flashy sort of I don't know reimagining
of what the game is and I'm sure it'll
be fun especially people have never
played the original but I'm so damn
close to the original you know is is I'm
looking at like alright so it comes out
March
20 on the PlayStation you know they give
n chilly down the road on xbox whatever
is like do I play it on the ps4 Pro or
do I just play it on the PS 5 or Xbox
around on it right because that's where
the next game if they ever make a sequel
to it is going to be anyways do I just
wait for them all to be finishing and
two-way ball back back okay I can't wait
that long
but um I think that we're gonna see the
episode 2 I think we were seeing episode
every two years
mmm let me actually still read let me I
should is what about what was actually
shown like it as far as the gameplay
style yeah that looks cool okay so we're
gonna Cranford and it was it was the
highlight yes we're annexes conference
cuz the rest of the show downward
trajectory yes talk about it someone
someone someone I don't even know man
you guys are you're trippin gospel about
squicky you're talking around
okay so Final Fantasy 8 remake that's
pretty cool
Nate's one of my favorite Final
Fantasies yeah what else did they show
like the party City Avengers I don't
know like it was like if you didn't
really care about Final Fantasy seemed
like you wouldn't have liked their
conference but the big the big thing
they showed off at the end was Avengers
which I'm not a fan of how it looks not
a fan of the way the characters look
back how the faces look I understand
we're about a year away from the game
coming out so okay that's not an issue
I'm not a fan of the character voices
because I love Nolan North and Troy
Baker and Ashley Johnson are iDate they
don't seem like they're trying to hide
their voices it's literally Ironman as
Nolan's Lord Bruce Banner as Troy Baker
it's like I can't I hear them and I'm
like wait a minute like you're not even
trying to con
do some sort of a center thank you and
what's face well I like doing the face
what what's up with the face I don't
know I don't know so much as I'm looking
forward to playing the game I'm like oh
these are ready kind of some negative
things and then then they try they
showed the trailer and it's like they
show those 22 seconds snippet of
gameplay but you can't really tell you
know its gameplay but it's edited in a
way where it's like okay so what exactly
is going on yeah I wasn't really that
impressed by adventures at all but I
mean I'll still check it out when it
comes out what May 20 2009 for me at
least was really the best first
impression so overall conference ranking
A through F sir granny through F I'd
give it a see okay see it is Lord addict
feeling very strongly about this oh are
you you have your impression sir yeah I
liked it I didn't like there's all a
couple low points I didn't really like
over odd think I'd give it like a C Co
plus there's I thought was better than
Microsoft but we all go into that right
now
you know I felt like final I feel like
the reason people think Final Fantasy 7
is gonna take forever to have another
one is because we a lot of people forget
that you know they they dished a lot of
the work that I think bad Namco was
originally working on they gave what you
know that Square Enix is fault why would
you outsource Final Fantasy seven that
makes no sense but anyway you know I
think we're gonna see a return quicker
because they because they actually have
the you know the engine and everything
settled out and they're working on it
internally now yes it's like they're
like full force and final fantasy now
and you know I what I really enjoyed is
it looks like that they're they're
making more of a narrative focus in this
game than they did the other ones mmm
because if you look at those trailers
there's certain scenes that just wasn't
in the original at all like no it wasn't
even hinted there's a time where cloud
first met Aerith and
there's like these little ghost things
that was around them and that wasn't in
the original game right all right
Oh was all jets corrected he said it was
air it rains make you mean they it
seemed like you know the original
characters that Jesse brings in them
like they're kind of building up on
those a little bit more what I liked
about is the very first book awesome
final fantasies that spider take thing
yeah and you know it had phases you did
enough damage to jump the walls so
hopefully you know they do more of that
and it's just not like one boss and so
I'm really excited about that mm-hmm
there's a couple thing I hope it's not
just to make art like that would be very
disappointing just amigo it's just a
Mingo so be disappointed like the
biggest scene I want to see in Final
Fantasy 7 remake is in Midgar but I
think that's a really weird time to to
cut it like if I were them I would cut
it after the past when when you go to
the next town and cloud explains what
happened like when he was in you know
the whole sefirot thing I don't want it
like spoil anything big the same with
the dress that's the best spoil a 20
year old game that is true how many
people is gonna be playing this has
never played it I don't know I mean do
you what people complain when you go
watch Titanic and the slip ship sinks we
are we are at a very vocal space now
okay people don't complain regardless
one look I understand not spoiling like
Avengers end game and movies that just
came out like a month or two months ago
but a for a video game that literally
released 20 years ago sorry we eyes in
the game 20 years you had better be
known happening that's why where I went
in and crowd and
is where the whole set for all think
happened in the past the biggest thing
that I want to really seize uh the scene
where you get captured at the the top of
the shin or a mansion their headquarters
they and cloud wakes up to like everyone
dead like that's the biggest scene I
want to see in seven because like that
was a pretty gory scene back then what
about the digenova
recap scenes where they I go in that
like was it the macro reactor in nipple
home that's gonna be great mutant in the
tubes and stuff there's a couple things
like I want to see when the weapons get
revived like there's a couple really
good seeds but just that particular
scene because you know this this is
exactly what I'm talking about there's
so many great memories from that game
yeah and if any one of them isn't in it
I'm gonna be like the games the whole
games ruin now the reason that
particular scene resonates more with me
is like I really like Sephiroth is a
villain and like that's the first time
he's introduced into that game to that
caliber like at first it like you know
he's just a myth you know no uh you know
cloud I really think we're climbing
really know like this guy so sick it is
gay that's cool you mute your mic so we
keep going on about the game that you
love so much and it did won the
conference know it is hot trash oh and
I'm gonna tell you this this is the
reason why it's hot trash is dis right
the fact that they told you they're
about to nickel and dime y'all and y'all
just like yo I'm lined up for that and
then you just said no they might do two
years increments and what point in time
is this acceptable and what point in
time is this you know what why don't you
take your whole game throw it in the
bushes and come to me when it's finished
is done oh you got the
ready your engine is smoking good so
smoke that engine up get that game out
and stop nickel in your ran just told
you to hold beginning and they can't
have the game done we already know what
the outcome is so what do you wanna do
you to jazz it up
so jazz it up already put the little
sprinkles on the top of it get the game
out and give us the same exact game that
you played that you want to play again
that's it now I'm tired of any
conference was know what they didn't
need a conference understand that you
salty understand that you salty they
needed a conference it's the only thing
they had been a download so I at least
they used what they had that's right
listen I ain't gonna front
so settle it if you think I'm gonna back
down from you when when you can only
afford for squares or you'll struggle
all right and for squares and everybody
gotta stand on the square up with the
bloody Avengers like why did they
you listen here we go listen you will
stop sitting here holder swing been
squid for a minute understand you
looking at an old faded champ that's
trying to be better
step back your boy is done I suppose
wobbly knees he wasn't good at all stuff
like Shenmue 3 ok so then again they
showed you the same trailer last year
now to give you a little bit of gameplay
right they were too long and you know
what in this phase right here ok show
nothing on human last you listen listen
listen I'm talking about
on what year was that they sure that was
two years ago I fell asleep for two
years
oh my god it's not my fault you're not
even noticing what's going on you do a
podcast or what god wait I know you
ain't talking you don't know half the
stuff they're going every day we got to
refocus I played a game 20 years ago
when it came loose stuff that's why you
buy the arcade sticks and all because I
told you so square was the worst
conference it was no no no it wasn't the
worst the entire with Bethesda Beaufort
them in the bushes 4f we got okay attic
finish your thing I know you've been
going on with my head I'm gonna be plush
just cuz of this dude but overall you're
ranking of the Congress as a whole like
B plus B plus all right in the curve a
b-plus I think I skipped you did you
watch I need a timber did you watch no I
call the Final Fantasy 7 stuff after the
fact okay I wasn't really interested in
anything else I don't like the Avengers
I think marbles so overrated oh I just
upset off the internet but I don't even
care like the fan oh snap Oh your
podcast party searching for a new
co-host
I don't know I clerked for a fancy high
school - you know he's that pretty much
all that showed avenges fall
investigated for about seven a lot of
JRPGs a lot of final fantasy amazed we
also the PlayStation Show not coming
xbox yeah he's right you know
I like fun upon CIA I'm always curious
if that if they're remaking that to
avoid to just to remove the pop song
that has the licensing issue or
something and that and I just thought
you know wife we were extracting that
part from the game II might as well just
remake the whole thing or something but
probably was because they got tired here
in that hash tag you coward it's like
that was a little every time that game
come up in remotely I literally would it
would train you cowards and that's from
Final Fantasy 8 gödel so Jezz from what
you see I know it's limited but if
either if you had to rank what you saw
what would you give it I probably give
it a say I'm already in the chatter I
saw something interesting where is it
again but it was like maybe we should
rate the shows based off of a you know
out of 10 Tim dog naps that's the rate
of it has a rate of it so we got that
from up from Jay's Lord soft forgive you
to finish this up um what do you got man
for swearing in and I gave him a D man
the only thing I really cared about
there was was the Final Fantasy it
looked good I'm glad they finally give
us some gameplay I want to see how Pete
how old school fans react because again
it's now the combat is a lot more
action-oriented I know they did things
to sort of alleviate that a little bit
with the slow motion where you can
actually pick and choose your moves and
your attacking to sort of make it feel
like it's more turn-based so we'll see
how that turns out but it looks pretty
um Avengers was disappointing to me and
then again and then it was the thing is
that what they showed was in
contradiction to what they said the game
was it was more open world and
everything looked very linear and then
if you see it did anybody see that at
over-the-shoulder off-camera leaked
gameplay that somebody okay so I saw
that it was very bad quality but what
you were able to see was a scenario
where all the Avengers are together
basically you could swap out back and
forth depending on the situation they
went from Hulk they went from Thor they
each had a little their little area that
they did but what it felt like like it
was very linear like it like section
pertain specifically to and a certain
avenger strengths and then we swapped
out to another avenger but also
cooperative like yeah you know it wasn't
co-op it was just you swapping back and
forth and he said it at the single that
the story campaign if not co-op it's
just you and you can swap out between
Avengers but it felt like every aspect
of each scenario was geared to a
specific avenger and their strengths so
it felt very linear very guided it would
look kind of pretty from what I could
tell it seemed like it move well Hulk
look good but I don't know if that's the
game that people want yeah in a way that
people reacted to Jedi fallen order yeah
it's just I don't know but on that game
oh yes good good on my game yeah so I
don't know I don't know so I gave him a
deal because that let's see Final
Fantasy was only thing I liked it like
like new.i there was too many too many
pointy-haired haircuts same constant I
gave a c-minus look Final Fantasy 7
remake is what I was here for initially
and they they they definitely knocked it
out the park I'm with addict on that
super high I liked what I saw yeah
they're gonna stretch it out most likely
yes King is right yes we know it's the
finesse but when you know how it is when
it's something you love you allow the
finesse to go down so kick is right with
the fraud on that part put on yeah I
thought it'd look good on as far as far
as everything else it was to me if your
it was a love letter to JRPG things if
you're a JRPG finish out stealth 40km
guys you love this show
you know shout to be money like that you
guys were in heaven cuz it's the show
for you in reference to that but for me
I was holding on to avenge so when they
say the to the very end and then I saw
what I saw and graphically with that
engine I'm like yeah we waited so long
- out there my man you know Uncle Dom
vici gaming you know good game and it's
just like it literally felt like
stunt-double guys like it like it like
it got a bunch of people together to do
a party for someone's children on how
the Avengers must look you didn't like
them not looking like them yeah there's
some banter on Twitter I was going back
and forth look I don't kid about like to
me it's like I understand with the
voices stuff like they they don't have
to mimic exactly how they sound in the
MCU sand you know cinematic but my thing
is like I look at Marvel Ultimate
Alliance 3 and those voices are
fantastic to me to me they represent the
essence of the character like at some
point like if I'm watching transformers
you could have your own rendition but
Optimus Prime has to have some type of
an archetype of his voice right it has
to be some thing that's true to the cat
it to me some of this was off and this
is an all-star cast so I just yeah I
think they were stupid for not trying to
make them sound like the MCU just
because like I get it but at the end of
the day the people you trying to sell
this to it then watch the MCU for like
the past 15 years like this day if
you're gonna go with your own direction
then don't mimic the look of the MCU
carry their mimicking look of the MCU
characters not the comics you don't say
and then they don't sound like it so
it's gonna see more jarring and that
engine I just wasn't there so for me see
- you know um it is what it is but we
are going to move on up Bethesda they
are up next who did not watch but this
this sucks cause like when the
conference was on I was working and like
other people so like in on the team like
one person was in charge of this show
one person was a joke I was in charge of
the export show so basically I tuned
everything now well I worked on the Xbox
stuff and I missed I missed that people
didn't seem didn't seem to like it that
much
mmm interviews I saw you know most the
interviews are so post e3 it's odd odd
Howard we're mostly just like what do
you guys suck now him defending himself
and full of zombie sex stuff like that
so I don't know basically why I heard
was do eternal good everything else me
ma'am
all right says with Jack I don't know
though I don't know I need to know
absolutely start with Lord rained Lord
of Bethesda himself Cognito my brother I
thought because this was slightly better
than Square Enix's doom eternal looks
s-slightly and I mean slightly as I'm
like right doom eternal looks great
can't wait to play November 22nd they
had like that kind of gameplay montage
towards the end which really sold it I
will give them credit for busting out
new IPs yes two of them one from Shinji
Mikami evil within I forget the name of
it goes viral yes that looks cool and
then you say the other one blue f loop
however you said that goals game look
cool I mean here's the thing here's the
thing all the concept I'll just see it
was all just CGI trailers oh I
appreciate new IP
however it's tough to really get truly
excited over CGI concept trailer plus
they get the Plus because they actually
came up with some new IPs even though
it's we have no idea when they're coming
out or what they'll actually play like
you know I'm assuming they're next gen
titles what else we got
fallout 76 who gives a [ __ ] language sir
I'll keep it you get your lot one swear
word on your loud be the one you know I
don't get a swear word now you are you
still have one package like it I swear
guest privileges these contracts now
what is it a fall 76 battle royale mode
interesting like okay but still I don't
know it just honestly it felt like this
III was just like an afterthought for
most of these companies and for everyone
right if for everybody for everybody now
you understand what ei is like yeah or
Activision is like we're not showing up
and so it's like see you in 2020 fools
right yeah so I better than it's better
than square coz the new IPs but the new
IPs were just CGI trailers that's that's
kind of my take on them Lord I'm very
curious about you but that's the come
cuz we what we together I felt like oh
you went with me we just got split up
yes may I offer and left like when you
were drinking yeah oh yeah free eye Lily
liquor I was next to Cognito and Lord
ghost yes yes no doubt no doubt so well
attic what you feel but that's the
conference and pressures and ranking sir
the only thing that looked interesting
was the like the time loot game all
making yeah I knew I give the copper 2d
oh wow okay not done spell for you all
that 76 thing oh here's a band-aid
that's all I heard about though the wow
the even with anything like okay I
didn't really like the other ones but
okay go do that with them they put a
battle royale in fallout 76 so I guess
that was cool but at least they're doing
is some kind of unique way I feel so too
but you know it's no doubt Lord
sovereign sitting right next to me
during the Bethesda cough and sleeping
in the beginning before it started but
we
they logo was talking you're standing
over the damn Sun baking yeah so what do
you think my impressions and ranking I
gave it a b-minus
let's start from the beginning like what
what I did not like is the sort of fake
may a culpa this whole we're all about
you we're here for you like they've
always been for years like you know what
but when you come out and say it like
that when you make it felt forced
considering how people felt about
fallout how people felt about the
elderscrolls blades like those two games
kind of really when you take two of
their their most well-known franchises
then you put out games that they sort of
stumble you know you get people gonna be
in their feelings about it right so I
get that but I would have preferred that
so kind needless I would prefer you know
Todd come on on stage and look shut to
shut the lights shut the music people
for a minute look we messed up here we
go this is how we're gonna fix it and I
think they did that when it comes to I
don't care about fallout 76 but they
came out and did everything that should
have been in the beginning and they
added it to the game right for free I
gotta give him that I got three free and
then everything else I got obviously
young on Wolfenstein Youngblood that's
coming out soon and that game looks
great online I don't play but they
actually keep adding to that game that
better and better and then the two IPS
that yes we always always with CG
trailers but the fact of the matter is
ghost why is the Shinji Mikami game I
don't have I have full faith in Shin
Makoku shoes yes that's Lou is arcane
have you never played this honor I've
never played it but you'd rather play
Final Fantasy seven for the umpteenth
time
who was saying that I like that game
did I not company those the opening
space that I said I liked that game the
ball they have not dropped the ball so
not be excited for ghosts war and death
loop is beyond me and then doom just
blew the rails of everything not like a
desk I need to point up okay like no you
wouldn't even have that you wouldn't
even have that point of comparison there
was no death stranding so you act like
yeah so they bouquet so they're saying
that they bit off of kijima now how they
snuck into into community feels a bit
off of confusion that was not near this
confusing woman the problem for Bethesda
is that they don't talk a lot of stuff
it's a QuakeCon she's in there the next
Elder Scrolls title or no one cares
shout out the dizzy with the super chat
continue your whatever you guys want and
that's the issue right like if people if
they're not talking about Elder Scrolls
they're not talking about fallout
everybody's like oh it's a wrap it's for
oh my god it's about people it's about
something that's like around people's
souls being taken from them and dropping
down the middle street show the Disney
the $2 super jet here at it go get a
Snickers but thank you did you play
disorder when I open my statement what
that's the only game I anything you'd
see just like the other stuff you need
to see anything mm-hmm
all of that I problem because ghost wire
has a passing resemblance in your eyes
to death stranding it's in the bushes so
you're recommending worse off just right
I gave them a b-minus
okay Lord King we gotta move on um what
do you feel sir
but then she felt very strongly in
passing during conversations in the
compound what did you feel about but
that's the show and Ricky he's in the
bushes oh we lost everybody hold on oh
yeah we good and rank dad's love we
still here yeah yeah exit Oh kings in
the bushes oh yeah hold on King travel
so we get King back he gonna get out
there but he was so disgusted with that
I don't know what's going on but um yeah
look I'll jump in on that um can we
solve it call me crazy conference like I
was talking with it shot the ate the
ruler shout out the bone you know and
while the conference is going on um I'm
literally saying to myself like this is
how you showcase your own IP he's like I
just I love the way they showcase it
then it's farmers on look I'm not gonna
I'm not the biggest Todd Howard fan can
be paid a bills real quick car to death
singing that's the loot Lords no ESO
slander
I've been playing since 2014 you go
death you do go ahead out yeah here so
it was they know they support the game
but um back on my mark my Todd Howard
like I'm not the biggest fan little
snarky I kind of wanted more of a me a
cobra based on how fallout so every six
kind of launched sorry Jess I know you
liked it but I will say this I am NOT a
fallout 76 fan but what they showed made
me interested and it was free and the
other battleworld stuff it was lit it
was the me a Copa conference on that
part I get it put on as far as like my
favorite yo I know attic don't like
concept stuff but I like what Ghost
Wyatt Tokyo was talking you know it
looked fire you don't say it has some
anime tropes and they know snapped ropes
and you don't say ninjas yo it looked
fired me then that other game on was it
deadlock with the flu or whatever yeah
like that drank with the mm that was I
want to see was about and then um I'm
not the biggest doing fan but do
internal look crazy look really strong
to me I like what they was doing and the
last thing I want to say is again when
it come down to present
nation shout out to the Orion streaming
tech they had stage they show does that
say a lot of fraud thing going on with
that someone did they uh someone they
kind of frou-frou frame-to-frame
yeah and the inputs wasn't what she was
putting listen all I'm saying regardless
to detect whatever the tech is what it
is
you're at a conference you want two
things to be shown so I I like that they
had the comments to at least put it out
there they had the camera guy over it
they're talking about Orion is supposed
to be something that's gonna help all
streaming services so stadia and X cloud
I'm excited to see the tech spoke to a
couple of people behind the scenes and
they are working with Bethesda on this
breakthrough so if that could even
improve streaming even more I'm excited
about that
did they have some filler yes where the
commander King things I was getting on
my nerves we're gonna get into that but
that was commander G that was re too
much for me it's for overall I like this
show but it's crazy and I'm not the
biggest but there's a guy like that but
I gave it a beat asked me King is back
to rain on my parade King
what was your impressions and of ranking
of Bethesda alright I'm gonna go in
person first yes right because my
impressions and my ranking different
greatly like I have split personalities
on this um now overall you know I got a
I got a preface this is this when I got
that was given the Royal Treatment the
drinks they knew I was going in with the
quinine I was out there because I don't
believe that got you drunk before it
yeah an open bar before the conference
you gotta understand like when you go
into these places and you know they give
you the drinks to get you ready but
doesn't knows how to how to give you a
show right they know the whole pomp and
circumstance I believe but does it is
more California than all of these
countries right so they know how to do
open outside air they know how to give
you the fool now notice all the stuff
I'm talking about has absolutely nothing
to a games right okay so now that
they'll average you up now beat you up
let slide you inside I'm not gonna front
they whole it's beautiful so you walk in
and get your video on he's sitting there
we sat there a little bit too long
be honest which one you scared I'm
having popcorn under the seats in the
light what no popcorn this year because
I heard they went out with the food
afterwards right but at this point in
time
remember I'm already coming from
Microsoft so I'm already tight harassed
because this has been a long day
alright so the show starts and they come
out with a Maricopa of what went wrong
I do appreciate any company that took
your hard-earned money and decided not
to bail on your game and in Doug and
people you know tell them about it tell
them about it that game look like it's
bailed on it is dead right um they
looking for the Ubisoft you got a look
at it for honor number four Anna was in
the bushes
and they brought that game back all the
way to this whole new DLC and I was like
it was this DLC is a new game he's like
I was like wow so for this company to
continually give you their best foot
forward
yeah they might make some missteps what
company doesn't you know but they give
you their best foot forward that
Wolfenstein that I was all about that
I'm about their presentation I'm about
all of that stuff I'm not about all
those our cell phone games that they
were showing I'm not about the this CGI
stuff of stuff that wasn't there but
they have to fill a show and this goes
into my hole who really needs a show you
don't sir you don't need a show um maybe
you can teach other people how to do a
show thank you maybe you can do that but
you are not that important enough to do
a show now as far as that doom go
everybody is all this doom is fantastic
I go play doing right now in game pass
that's the same exact way
you don't know I pull up my numbers I do
so please I don't think you played oh
but listen listen I touch doom eternal I
like dual maternal and I like do when it
comes out imma get it that's what's
gonna happen but was it some drastic
okay alright
it's doom eternal whatever um for the
photos diehards cuz he's frauding you
right now but don't miss doom alright
and that was the backbone of this show
to be honest with you and I think um on
on that note they were way better than
Square Enix I don't even know why swings
he just showed up um they okay they
should get a c-minus
I'm gonna give him a deal okay the
reason why I just don't want them there
I don't want I don't want I don't want
to encourage I don't you don't want to
encourage something that shouldn't be
happening
III for your personal dislike thank God
you did like it thank God they were
there because certain people that took
your money didn't show up at all so
thank God they were there to fill up a
gap in a day so you think what if they
had the next I was correct what if they
had that was would that warrant the
conference or no not you know
elderscrolls alone deserves its own
conference conference and put it on
Sony's conference I take elder scrolls
and put it on you know the desease up
alright or Microsoft
listen audio all right well you gotta
say the vibe did you buy it
mmm no they're a publisher yeah I'm
talking about a developer I'm talking
about a manufacturer of hardware
those guys need conferences that's what
I want so basically the public you don't
want publishers know you know I'm always
be consistent with this I do not want to
see you left to make it hard with that's
just as you've been consistent I'll give
you that I don't agree well you have
been consistent I have to give you we
gotta get us on that we got a blogger we
got by respected thank you even though I
don't you see oh damn moving on flying
through Ubisoft who didn't sit everyone
Soren I wish Lord kognito
yes ubisoft's I probably give it a
c-plus they started out strong I can i
with no interest in watchdogs Legion
absolutely none not because I don't like
watchdogs I do but as I said yeah I
don't know if I want to play another
watchdogs I played two of them you know
whatever and they showed off the trailer
oh and then there's oh he's permadeath
and all this stuff and I'm like yeah
whatever I didn't then they did the
unthinkable at a show they showed a
10-minute gameplay demo and I was sold
on watchdogs legions from the gameplay
demo we're talking about like was just
presented well in that demo it got me
excited to try it out or play it in
March of next year
and then after the demo they did a
trailer and the trailer was just bad I'm
like man thank God they did the demo
because I wouldn't have cared and then
the rest of the conference was just
Rainbow six siege
Rainbow six quarantine with the CGI
trailer come on what else
what else do they even have that was not
awesome mobile game with your boys oh
yeah yeah the rainbow mobile the mobile
game I think they have for honor come
out again someone help me what else to
Ubisoft even God and ring being or not
not respect to gestate show against
Ghost Recon breakpoint with John birth
panel on the CGI trailer role of
champions did but they just showed how
is the world of champions of was good
it's still I mean it's obviously very
early but I mean it it seems fun cuz
it's like one of those things like you
you know you grab the ball you got to go
around a certain number of times be able
to score and depending on how many times
you can get around without getting
knocked or getting the ball stolen is
the amount of points you get so from
what I saw like there isn't too much in
the way of animations when you're
knocking someone over so there's running
somebody over I think if they decided to
go more over the top with it like like
like the NBA Jam of rollerblading games
if it might be more interesting to me
but right now it's it works this is like
a chat please hit that like button
really really appreciate it
continue hit the like button let's go
hit that like button smash it what a
vision two updates and I just like to
you know whatever and that TV show from
that's always sunny which was fun funny
it was so cringy and I'm a big fan of
It's Always Sunny so yeah there I give
him a C+ for the demo because man you
know like demos are in short supply
these days
hey man I don't just say that hey I need
I need I need game play at my listen I
got body bags yes excuse me
for you you know we're coming for you K
ain't gonna hold back gonna be able to
batter attic in a corner watch I love
this long at a time realizing that I
don't have the voice to continue arguing
this is when your idols become your
rivals just know he's gonna jump in on
the backside because Jeff was right
there trust me I know fly through um so
that again just to confirm was a see
what was it brand I'm sorry you're a
c-plus all right attic let's fly through
come on you saw you saw okay see all
right now give it a D D Wow no standout
for you no okay Lord saw impressions
breaking C - I like watchdogs breakpoint
and what I've seen of it before you look
really good but they do get it they get
they get a fold from me and what they
did to me and Lord
MJ outside sequestered you mean when
they messed up and thought they had no
more seating when they actually have
plenty of seating so next year
let's get that worked out stroke the low
MJ being a real one on that that's
what's up but um so what your ranking
was you said see yeah I give him a
seating - all right Lord King really
quickly Ubisoft what was your impression
in your ranking I thought they had good
games there but again I don't feel like
um you know they deserve a conference so
yeah it's just that they're always gonna
get a deeper me post but I must say um a
couple of the games did pique my
interest and like I said I love
companies that sit there and fight for
the games that are that definitely
didn't start off on the best feet yeah
so when you act
you can show that you're gonna make sure
that a game stays through when they
respect your dollar that's that that
comes very few and far between with
these companies a lot of times they're
on to the next one so if you see your
favorite game still being represented
through all these conferences from
initial release and they still have
something going through even if it's a
little tidbit I know a lot of you guys
don't like to see see it thieves every
hour Microsoft conference but the fact
that they took your money and they
continue to give you content on your
games I'm just saying you support your
late games but they get a different me
pause real quick oh yeah baby I give it
a see arm watchdogs legions like Moran
says super strong wasn't that height for
watchdogs coming in actually was sad
that it got leaked but then when I saw
shut up the granny December yo granny
getting busy oh no dad I think that I
got a high I go for unlike um actually
like corn I mean it
graphical slice or whatever but I like
the concept of quarantine PvE just which
was morning three players breakpoint I'm
a Bernthal fanboy I loved his inclusion
in it they need to show gameplay though
um that's really it after that it was
straight filler dance dance is in the
bushes
I mean shelter piscatella I know he said
that that thing sells like hotcakes
that's why they gonna continue to
support it it's just you don't need to
bust out a full concert on my conference
that's uh I wasn't about that
Oh Sam fish or mobile felt from ran so
bad so yes you're evil I saw your tweets
you're like I just he just relegated to
new beast off is trolling and me I saw
we did a piece outside all much gaming
down net right after the conference and
we were just like they just feel the
disrespect to Splinter Cell fanbase
I don't know myth the quest who tells
what the hell that was about so see for
me we're gonna move on Nintendo and
Microsoft the main event let's get to it
in ten do is up arm
ignored Jets did you see it no I didn't
see the direct itself but I yeah I like
Nintendo I've looked into it quite a bit
it's interesting because I saw that the
Pope I'm a big Pokemon fan
oh yeah I son I saw the the Pokemon
gameplay trailer oh my god this looks
amazing and it was the details that came
out afterwards that Pokemon community up
in flames right now really what happened
well if you look on if you look on like
any of the big Pokemon community
websites like the subreddits II even
Japanese for from the stuff everyone's
angry because Game Freak is basically
said that they're only gonna bring
forward a select amount of Pokemon and
well to transfer Pokemon from Pokemon
bank yeah there's only gonna be a few
dozen Pokemon mega evolutions have gone
zedd music on so and they're done this
to try and balance the game a
competitive play or Jack Assyrians feast
right now people are mad wow man because
I mean God look at this like ratio
there's like thirty five thousand
dislikes um Wow is that true I mean I
believe it's true but I'm saying it I
didn't know was this serious Wow
khadijah so people might like look at
the hashtag like bring back the national
dex on twitter so people are mad about
that um our neck because like that they
say the new Pokemon sitting in Britain
it's like they're calling it Dex it kind
of nice meaning to say that but could
you case tougher continuous yeah other
than that we had like banjo in Smash
which I didn't like Rand was saying run
deciding for months that he was hearing
banjo has come to smash and I was just
like I don't think so man I don't think
so no but I was like I didn't have
information I was just sort of going off
my gut instinct because when I've been
to rare a couple of times since people
I'd asking about banjo in Smash and each
time I've been to rare I've asked them
so whenever getting banjo smash and they
just gave me such an amazing poker face
oh I'm just like I was just like man
banjo ain't coming like I just kind of
felt like Microsoft wanted to leave the
IP dead and if I added banjo to smash
that would just increase the noise of
people asking for new games and stuff
they did it so we got banjo and smash
now so maybe that means we'll have more
bunch of games in future I don't know
and other than that you know loads of
other cool stuff like you know Link's
Awakening got a closer look at that
awesome Animal Crossing also looks
awesome just got a lot of good stuff
coming and you know as well I give I
give an intended like a B+ I don't
disagree with you I probably give them a
bi like I don't care about it done right
I do not care about Nintendo but they
know how to speak to their fans about
the games you know coming out this year
yeah okay Animal Crossing we're delayed
to 2020 they give you their good reason
why um and then of course you know it's
like they have the banjo reveal which
I'd known about I don't know like six
months ago
I just kept undoubting me on that one
but I'm like no jazz it's coming you
tell me you definitely know I mean I I
mean I told you I was told that it was
coming I don't get documents I don't get
that stuff but anyways and then the end
with Zelda Oh breath of the wild sequel
which is and Nintendo just great at that
right like everybody knows they're
obviously gonna be making a new Zelda
but like Nintendo's like alright it's in
production here's a 30 second trailer
see in four years 12 years and I'm like
man and then like the fanbase gets so
excited because now they know for sure
is all this comment yeah when you get
the fanbase super pumped up you know
like sometimes I wish Microsoft would
just take a page sometimes
what so your ranking was what over I
give him like it probably would be
higher if I gave you know a crap about
Nintendo but I give him a B I think it
was probably the strongest showing out
of anybody your point you still yeah
yeah and if he does I'm spreading that
and if you know the more people that
know the more people have to force run
to do it lower him into playing again
game school look at it quickly
Nintendo oppressions you know rating
they killed it oh all right all the way
we'll just stand out for you know the
whole thing I didn't really like that
good pacing they had good concert like I
really didn't see any issues with their
game like obviously some of the games I
didn't care about but for every game I
didn't care about literally the next
game I cared about so I you know they
killed it's probably the best drug
they've had years oh let's go Lord salt
switch brethren in the house what's
going on which hold that came home they
did they did exactly to Kings Point
right the fact that he publishers he
feels don't should not have a conference
cool I get that that said I think the
big three should be held to a higher
standard
Nintendo understands that so I don't
care if they tell me about a game is
five years out so we go and like they
didn't spend a whole direct last year
talking about that smash
I was getting a from me King there we go
today we go to the manufacturer that
actually showed up here oh no right now
from the get-go you understand Nintendo
knew how important this was last year
they stunk to join up I'm talking about
the whole California smell like scoots
like to this bag but I'm gonna give you
this those dudes came to party they came
to rock they came out with Bowser they
did the little skit I was like yo they
actually out here you know and he's a
little bit more personable than Reggie
Reggie you know and I know Reggie
sitting there like with a little salt
bag like oh I do i do love every game
that came out maybe some games wasn't
for me
but i'ma tell you this they knew who
they was talking to every time they did
when they had a little expanded directs
on stuff I redid deep dives on games
that did people really wanted to see so
to to have your big franchises right
with the Zelda's popping up Luigi
mansions those games these games was
highlighted they show gameplay they
showed your games and the best possible
light
right I am a little concern that Luigi's
Mansion did have a release date though
I'm not too concerned cuz they look like
there was jam-packed with games like it
was jammed that's what that's what I
brought myself good point
um they knew this is the time to make
your presence felt now their presence at
e3 Hall is always film right floor and
all times they have probably that's why
Microsoft pulled a stuff out of there
I'll betray you right now if you came to
the hole you came for Nintendo and
that's exactly how it always gonna be
but the fact that Sony wasn't there
Nintendo understood they had to double
up right they had to come and bring
their a-game and that's why they get an
A+ from me
and matter of fact to be honest would
you get an S ranking because I'm not
gonna lie to be in a position that they
are and to show out the way they did
they give they're giving you a zelda now
and if they go by the way that Zelda
that you really liked if this really one
is not really a joint we do have that
breath for a while to download for you
check that out look that over and that's
coming your way boom and you know and
that's how you do it you drop that a
bomb on top of somebody's head so they
can't say nothing any Walkman King I
respect shot they are the ground a game
and lower fines being very disrespectful
he's that sure all is gonna be looking
like a Picasso painting on the switch
you said that which or switches moving
like those rudolph movies from the 60s
very disrespectful we're gonna move more
from him you're up with UK kick shots i
wish you were like they killed it they
killed it um just a love letter to the
base um
exclusive tremendous exclusive title
dropping astra trained most of Marv
Ultimate Alliance three par Mario Party
dragons class
Pokemon so itself awaited after hit bang
after bang I mean um even the poets like
who would have thought Witcher is even
able to run on it we still haven't seen
it but like what type of sorcery is
going on here with this port shout out
to all the dudes that ID and Bethesda
using an engine they got Wolfenstein I
was able to see that behind the scenes
to talk with the devs and like it's just
impressive what
able to do and how Nintendo was working
with them you have to give it up to
Nintendo for allowing the chip to be
used because they are underutilizing the
chip on purpose and as they're trickling
out this extra and there's not even deaf
kids they just allowing them to use more
of the power of because what was
explained to me Lord Jesse Lauren was
that you know because of their whole
concern of the portability aspect Lin
Tendo would restrict devs on the
functionality of unlocking more of the
chip and now they're getting them free
rein
so yeah battery life is gonna suffer but
they'd rather get the performance boosts
so just to hear that kind of stuff is
refreshing intended working with these
guys like that
I mean just like um Lauren said the only
staff fool was probably Animal Crossing
and then they got in front of it right
they said look it's not coming out this
is why boom boom boom
you know I'm saying and I know a lot of
people don't like all of it right now so
it's just like yo I got you good oh no
I'm not gonna sit there nitpick when
they show me like it's not really
nitpicking like they're showing an IP
that they introduced after Bayonetta 3
like but not Bayonetta 3 action 3 might
be in the bushes may think it might've
gotten cancelled it's still like I don't
understand how you show again that you
announced after you now say no oh no I
got it I got a throw a flag on a frail
squeenix sure was great at a Nintendo
Direct flag on a field he's in drinking
that juice we really believe in our
final fantasy and I gotta say god bless
for those people that holding that flag
but I don't want you to keep that same
energy when they drain your pockets all
right they're gonna drip dry you for 10
years your grandkids don't play the last
ending chapter that game there's no
pockets dry - but that's the I'm just
messing with Sloan that's the whole
thing but up not like again like Rand
said
no truly understands the nuances to
their hardcore base and an MP deep muff
least freaking out everyone that was at
the at the show feel like the platform
over there was only was the cave though
so we go get it to the main event and
why we are here a lot of people wanted
the Lord's impression they want rands
impression and one Jazz's raw impresses
he's back you know he's so we gonna get
into Microsoft man and um let's get to
it
Lord yes Lord ran weapon wants to start
first on what were your I say they fight
to the death
I don't know King like I think people
would be surprised like I think I'm
gonna be a lie you a little bit always
start without the Philly good follow the
Lord's just want to say again I called
III told you they would show games not
necessarily your games love this podcast
lovely to brother thank you so much for
follow some check Lord jazz let's start
with you - lets go I'm ready to be the
minority on this one I think as usual
but I didn't think it was that bad
everyone else seemed everyone else okay
keen killer I know what you gonna say
right after I just allow demanded get
its platform to seek second field tell
me just what this is why ready pal the
point is how I'm going for the same
reasons most other people like a as soon
as it ended I was like wait about it
because like we didn't see much meat I
think I tweeted out something like it
felt a lot of it was smoke and mirrors
like almost like watching a Michael Bay
movie where there's action going on you
can't actually see the action early
Transformers movies I wanna read that it
cuts is so like the camera angles and
the cuts are so rapid and
and you can't absorb what you're saying
like I feel like either they pack too
much in or it wasn't long enough and I
think like the gears 5 the gears segment
was travesty like I genuinely think that
whole segment was a travesty like like
teasing us with celebrities and that
it's super chat real quick I'm a reader
super checks boxes plus I went into it
is I'm compromised
shout out the Phil you deal with Sony
didn't bring pso2 to the west firefight
and you know the worst part about that
whole gears fiasco I'm not a huge Gears
fan but I walked a couple reactions you
know what announcement they did right
after gears but the elite rose to like
what when they went out people was
low-key expecting something more on
gears and then it went to that black
screen showed the next control and
people like it's like that made it worse
that made it in ten times worse almost
it was it was just a mess
almost every reaction I heard was like
another control I've seen that
controller because all of my leaks from
2017 on that controller a completely
accurate battery now every single aspect
of that controller when we delete it
great recordings I like saying that but
you know he's a great leaking I was like
well I didn't even remember that the get
the controller came after gears because
I was sitting there dumbfounded at how
bad it was but because I am a Gears fan
I'm a big gears fan you know I've got
like I got all the merchandise I got
like a huge bloody replicate and so that
I don't even know where to put it it's
just against the wall and it's like can
I get it to Germany when my girlfriend
like
I don't think but it was just like
where's the campaign gameplay with this
going off aside mode and they really
show off probably because you said these
guys are gonna get to play it now but
not you and we sort of choreographed
trailer that didn't really tell us what
he was like after the trailer I went and
played it and I was like oh I get it now
right but most the vast majority of
people weren't there to have the
privilege of track playing it so I
suppose it's good in a way because it
falls on me to write content about it
and then Microsoft would be like you
know looking to press to to rely that
experience yes I said that same exact
thing the kognito and I'm glad you
eloquent in this point because I feel
that they using fan fest as a vehicle to
get information and content out that
they don't want to delve deep into
because Skype was good it was like I
played it and it was you know and I felt
like they could have showed it in a much
better light and they did on stage but
you know beyond the gear segment you had
like just so much rapid story it was
hard to really process everything that
we were saying like they should have
whoever storyboarded this show they
should have had segments that slowed
everything down a bit you know instead
of this super fast paced stuff that
should have been a longer gear segment
it should have maybe even been a bit of
Halo infinite gameplay just so we could
see expect you know cyberpunk had
gameplay last year an hour an hour's
worth of gameplay there is no reason why
we couldn't have had halo infinite
gameplay if it's coming out next yeah
there's no reason don't Punk spin it and
then exactly what I said yes you did the
cyberpunk is gonna release even more
gameplay in August so we'll have had two
hours worth of cyberpunk 2077 gameplay
two years ahead of launching
and we've got zero hello infinite
gameplay except for this trailer which
did look pretty cool and I and I on a
Halo fan and in just the record but I
understand like how frustrating it was
for this little tease and I think like
if the if the expectation on Microsoft
wasn't as high as it is right now to
know biggest criticism of theirs which
is if it people would have been a little
bit more forgiving like I feel like they
had an opportunity to really respond to
all the criticisms in the last couple of
years and they didn't I don't condemn it
and you could argue that maybe they
don't need to maybe next year they bring
the big guns but how many years now have
like Oxfam means pain let's wait till
next year
let me ask two questions before I let
you go if I get the RAM you had a
tremendous article on project gets cloud
so I want to I want to focus a little
bit on this to it sense that did you
feel that project has cloud silence
they're haters or the skeptics and then
the second it's obviously you know we
both have seen cyberpunk just in general
the importance of that game for myself
well first of all with X cloud like I am
we've been we've been covering X cloud
on Windows central since 2013 as they we
leaked an all-hands meeting at Microsoft
where Microsoft came before the
employees and they showed up Halo four
running on Lumia phone and were like
streaming from in an internal prototype
server rack and they were like this this
is the future of what we're going to do
so we've been covering this since 2013
and to finally like get it in in our
hands I mean it's not in a Windows Phone
sadly but to finally get that that
vision realized is kind of magical
because it actually works and you know
I've tried on live I've tried
PlayStation now they're both terrible
mm-hmm I mean with fairness tax that I
haven't tried on my own home internet
yet so and it was streaming to the
Microsoft a dedicated Wi-Fi signal in
the more
softly to a data center that's 400 more
miles away and and that you know that's
that's that serious amount of distance
and with that knowledge like to be able
to hear every active reloading gears
with no issues with the latency able to
kill the two hunter the two hunters in
the opening segment of Halo 5 like
precision aiming and love in the back
let go low hunters you know well the
little orange stuff is the worms and
that to be able to do that without any
issues on a phone streaming it's huge
you know and and the difference the
difference between that and stadia
assuming both of them actually do work
when it comes out
devs don't have to do any development
work to get their games rain on Xcode
and like no Linux based like state we
stayed here they have to port to Linux
they have to add the the Google API and
all that stuff but with with X cloud
because it runs on xbox Xbox consoles so
converting to server racks they don't
have to do any work they don't have to
add any api's they can add the like
there right there is a xbox streaming
API now which they can leverage to
change the size of UI elements because
there can be hard to see on the screen
and also add touch controls there are
things to get around that if developers
want to use them but I don't have to use
them they can just literally dump their
game on X cloud and it'll just work and
for I think like it's incredibly
exciting you know because it's it's like
a Holy Grail to get your games no matter
where you are and that's why the switch
that's why I think the switch has been
so popular absolutely it fits in around
your life you know you can be you can be
anywhere and play anywhere and I'm
excited for that cyberpunk or we saw the
extended press demo which was longer
than the demo that on the floor this was
like 55 minutes it was it was absolutely
breathtaking incredible like that I mean
I will say like there are some slight
concerns I have like that the AI seemed
to get stuck as it was transitioning
from one move to another and like they
did say that some of
stuff we polished which is you know I
they did have handout like feedback
leaflets so people could yeah yeah I I
said I just wanted the gunplay to feel a
little bit more impactful when I filled
out my survey as well what did you put
for your feedback yes uh yeah I just put
like the AI needs to tighten up a bit
like there was this there was this boss
fight against like this huge cyborg lady
with a sledgehammer yeah with the thing
I'm back yeah yeah and like it was on it
was an awesome set piece but she her AI
was really dumb well I agree by all the
AI reactions seem really slow so I was
that basically I was my only negative
feedback when it comes to like the
amount of stuff you can do the branching
dialogue the decisions and consequences
it feels like old school man like the
feels let me back to that fallout 3 yes
like you've got tons of dialogue options
that is building your backstory where is
like like original Bioware - yeah like
if it feels like that much attention to
the impact of your decisions and stuff
like that and like thread that that
short mission like the basically the
mission was you basically playing two
gangs off against each other on a hunt
down for information and but like even
in that mission you do use the option to
complete it with completely non-lethal
takedowns you could go in guns blazing
and reduce everyone to bloody chunks
like shooting the heavy machine guns
Allah would rather wish you go like
terminator tip it off because there yeah
rip you can hack the turret you can rip
the Tauri out of the floor and just
carry it around and shoot people with it
or you can like just disable the Tauri
if you want to play completely stealth
and then there was like these these like
why is that could cut people in half and
stuff like that it was just crazy like
so supersize firing the violin like you
I mean I love that kind of stuff you
know and most there's this controversy
now where games can't be too violent but
I don't think a game can be to rap
because I know we got a lot you're like
it's roughly over but it's what you gave
it overall for the conference I give it
a b-minus
I do while I was disappointment lack of
CGI if you actually I said this to Rand
I think if you watch the conference in
slow motion it's a lot better like you
can see what bleeding-edge is supposed
to be you can see what minecraft
dungeons is supposed to be and they did
have a lot of great content in there it
was just so poorly explained that it
wasn't until after the show and I got on
the floor and I played the game for
myself I played Minecraft dungeons for
myself played bleeding-edge for myself
and play gears escape for myself on all
of those games
it wasn't until then that I started
being more excited about why Xbox had to
offer in the future but most people
didn't get that experience and it's a
shame that Microsoft I mean it's good
for me is press because I get to write
about it and get some clicks you know
but I feel like Microsoft owes it to the
fans to try and bring that experience
onto the screen and I don't think I did
that so even though that guy had a lot
of good content I don't think the show
was well put together so I give it a bit
- oh Lord
Rand we were in the DMS during an e3 we
had a lot to say to each other I'm dying
to hear your appearance my first time
really getting adapt to you what were
your impressions of the Microsoft press
here we go look I hate being negative
about really anything I'd rather be
positive about stuff but honestly the c3
was probably the worst one I've seen
ever and I really mean ever
there wasn't one like Nintendo was
strong but I don't care about Nintendo
okay
governor stuff really excites me yeah
like as a whole like every conference
was just underwhelming okay and the
poster child for underwhelming was
Microsoft's conference why whoa it was
one of the most boring presentations I
have ever seen them put on like Oh God
and what Jess said is right whoever did
the storybook storyboarding and where to
put things and the reliance on quickly
cut to minute gameplay trailers and CGI
trailers
I don't know like I just was not a fan
and I know some people who say well you
got over hype for absolutely not are you
kidding me when filled on Twitter and
said we have 14 games at the show I did
a video and I was like how are the 14
games that are gonna be there and I said
no late season walking's type of times
you would what was bleeding edge and I
thought there would be a second one well
I was wrong on that it was just one new
game and it was just bleeding edge so no
I wasn't overly hyped for this
conference I thought last year's was
magnitudes better this year was just
like it's it's really tough to put into
words how disappointing the show was
when the best part of your show is a
cameo from a Hollywood actor that's not
your game that you took there a party
game and they're just a third party game
and then you follow up that high-energy
moment with 25 minutes of indie gameplay
and a talking head coming out to give us
a spiel about game paths no and it's not
because I love indie games I think
spirit fair looks cool a lot of those
games look really interesting but it's
like you missed a moment to transition
from cyberpunk and the emotions and the
high that people have I don't know maybe
show Gears 5 immediately after and do a
gameplay demo but I forgot we weren't
doing gameplay for Gears 5 even though
it comes out in three months we're gonna
do a stupid CGI trailer I'm sorry I will
like look I said it in the besides the
thing it's always good though
I was horrible that was like all your
old remix or an eight year old remix or
whatever there's a thing I will give I'm
not a fan of CGI trailers if it's your
first time announcing a game I will give
you a pass so I'll go Swire game the
death look game from Bethesda if it's
your first time okay that's cool concept
I get it but if your games coming
on three money whoa I don't want to see
a CGI trailer and then I'd go watch it
like you want to see the gameplay that
you here for well go check it out mixer
with these WWE superstars no I'm sorry
you get a zero out of that that is a
feeling grade alien grade for that
presentation they destroyed all the hype
surrounding gears and I you wonder why
the gears thing gets to me but after
watching that was there hiding the
single-player because they think it's
bad and when it's your first thought
when if someone's first start to think
why aren't they showing this
single-player campaign and your first
thought is hey it must be really bad if
they're not showing it three months from
launch that's not a good thought to have
so I absolutely hated the gear segment I
hate that run I literally said that to
executives on the floor like it was like
I was like it's not your fault but it
feels like you're hiding something
because this whole anthem thing was
fresh in my mind like all anthem
Cataclysm drama where they were like oh
by the way this is the Cataclysm an
anthem I showed of this amazing storm
and stuff at e3 and then what we get is
actually just some of the sort of blue
color and a few leaves blown around I
mean obviously you could tie I didn't
like to show I'm not gonna argue with
anybody over it if somebody else loves
the show great before you be - I know
I'm sorry is this dude there was just so
many missed opportunities here like the
scarlet reveal it's like deja vu I was
at his trailer three years ago it was
tragic Scorpio and it's like okay fine
cool whatever I could deal with that the
X cloud info there was not enough info
like after the conference is over people
were talking like X cloud was going to
be free the whole thing was free but it
was like what is it discounsel streaming
or or the remote play or the X cloud
stuff's free obviously it's just the
console streaming is free I want to jump
in on on scarlet I want to backtrack to
one second right now
first today's a lot of stuff going on
with the Scala prevalence as far as
verbage we heard things as our most
powerful council you have a video out
right now it kind of talks about that we
hear dual skew as far as a lockhart
anymore and i just want to touch on that
part did you feel really good I mean we
don't I know we don't know but just
what's your gut is reference to how
they're handling the Scarlet thing do
you think it's a situation where they
may not be as powerful so they want to
be careful or they just don't know
playstation what they gonna do and then
change their approach and got rid of
lockhart as well i think they probably
don't really know so they can't really
come out because they can't come out and
say we're the most powerful and then
sony ends up being more powerful because
i this is the thing like Matt Bowie said
an interview today that it is
definitively more powerful really like
some of the other execs have been like
really like I asked Mike Ibarra in our
interview and he was like being more
powerful is important to the team is
that is that that's what he basically
said and that's kind of sort of what
feels said to unjoin bar but Matt Boone
it was like oh yeah we're the most
powerful blow bar but obviously Matt
Bowie isn't directly involved with the
engineering team so I don't really take
his his word as gospel and so I I I you
tonight when when I when the prevailing
rumor was it was going to be Sam with
es5 was gonna be sandwiched between
anaconda and lockhart but now it looks
like Lockhart's been shelved i don't
think it's i don't think you can just
assume that the ps5 is gonna be less
powerful than ligase I'm not I'm not
still 100% sold on it being shelved I
think and I said this is my preview
video that I thought they wouldn't
mention Scott they wouldn't mention
Lockhart at all because it like what is
Lac what does Lockhart do for you it's
right it's the cheaper price what can
you not talk about a year and a half
before launch the pricing in the system
so it makes no sense to talk about how
powerful your system is gonna be and
also oh we have this cheaper one so I
felt they weren't gonna mention Lockhart
at all now there are some interviews
floating around from Phil that mentioned
consoles plural like I just watched one
earlier there's a block
from 343 that talks about you know their
next gen consoles plural so I'm not 100%
convinced that Lockhart is officially
canned I think they're just talking
about project scarlet as it refers to
you know the Xbox anaconda right that's
a quick [ __ ] rent shout to Philly you
go to see which files which I the next
box no matter what you're getting will
blow away the one you have now buy a ton
if you claimed not to be impressed I
dare call you a liar okay good to know
so I mean like look I understand people
like the show understand people didn't
like it I'm not claiming to speak for
anybody else other than myself I didn't
like it I was disappointed I told Phil
as much I said I thought it was one of
their worst shows and we had a nice
discussion about it and yeah so if you
like to show more power to you I'm not
gonna argue with you I'm not gonna tell
you you're wrong I just felt I just felt
it was boring I thought the pacing was
screwed up I didn't think they showed
enough and that's weird to say because
they showed 14 Xbox game Studios games
but I don't care I mean like Forza
horizon DLC you know like stated DLC it
I don't really care for DLCs taking up
stage presence at least see a thieves
wasn't there yes plus yeah so I mean and
I did say that I felt Mike next year's
way more important to Microsoft and for
everybody so I was I was expecting
Microsoft to basically hold back and
they did but then again of course that
basically means wait for e3 2020 and
people been saying that for years
so my grade for the show is a d you
supposed to say b-minus but trying to
stay Suh Lord addict bu and solve had a
very passionate interview on a Louis
game when that net right after the show
so I got to get it from your man what's
going on
what do you feel Microsoft let's get it
comes to Microsoft you know I actually
had to go back and you know right
all the stuff that they announced yes I
did a show when I got home yeah like
look alright I think initially I gave it
a D did not get my heart I don't like to
bump that up to a c-plus and the reason
I had to do that I don't I still a
hundred percent debrief everything I
said mmm-hmm
but you attacking me during the show
saying [ __ ] this is sponge
no it's still spooky it's just like I
looked at it from a standpoint that
conference on paper would have been
great okay let's just say they executed
everything about the conference wrong
mm-hmm like for instance if they would
have had more of those Indies in a row
had some wasteland gameplay ahead some
more outer worlds gameplay had gears
gameplay you know it would have
heightened that overall conference like
if you think about it like the
conference had almost and all the
studios regardless how it was I grew up
ran I don't think DLC should be on the
biggest stage of the year but it was
there so we have to we have to accept it
so you know they had all that you go
from a D to a C+ he says spooky I say B
you say you were from a D to a C+ he
said you spooky but you know at the end
of the day the conference itself was
good it was well paced but they just
didn't execute anything right today they
didn't show any game plan anything at
all in that that's disappointing the
stuff that they could have shown that
they had realists like what was that um
the game from from software thing that
the way they did like you know I get it
you know just as you're talking this
this for maze is the central point I
can't remember half the stuff you're
talking about mm-hmm remember half the
stuff you talk and that's that's the
issue because though like you guys
remember the deer game though like two
minutes of it like in the standpoint of
waste line three the trailer they showed
didn't even really show what kind of
game
once white you know that's the part that
just blows my mind it's like okay I was
disappointed there's no fable I think we
all went into there you know 5050 and
that there was gonna fail okay no fable
and fell free when I fell I hate that
but at the end of the day Sony's not
there they're not gonna shoot the
bazooka when you know there's no one to
shoot of that so I stand that I
disappointed as a fan but I understand
it as the business move mm-hmm oh they
dropped the ball halo mm-hmm
so you were not in for some people were
emotional so I'm not a fraud doc there's
no like nostalgia completely grab their
hair we got a good body
so like rancid so the question about
infinite why are they frothy I'm curious
they didn't show us anything to be like
extremely excited about they literally
just showed okay if you think about it
you know I thought the game looks better
than halo but they didn't even really
give us a valuation of what that energy
can look like in a real circumstance we
was in a dusty ass [ __ ] straight
language we was in a dusty [ __ ] that had
no no lighting really whatsoever so you
couldn't see any kind of lighting
particles anything like that obviously
you're not on any kind of planet size so
you can't see textures on how grass
looks how the water is we've seen that
Chatwin annoying you it is like how are
you doing that but you getting hype
about Final Fantasy 8 going anyway great
they showed like 12 minutes of Final
Fantasy 7 gameplay so you want to sit
down nice to fight the Final Fantasy 7
game place you got to sit like all that
you know it's the story completely I
don't understand like they do when it
comes to that well I actually looked up
if you look if you follow halo faller
they actually have a really breakdown of
that trailer well it takes someone
pausing frame to frame to understand
anything remotely what's going on and
it's like they didn't the only lighting
we saw is when he opened it at the end
we don't know what the enemy is we don't
know where they are
well you don't even know why Master
Chief was out in space
like that that is true called plankton
oh hey I like that that way we are like
right and I was thinking maybe you know
this perspective isn't Katy like
assuming you played halo wars too and
I'm like okay 80% of the people who play
Halo 5 around go play love wars - so you
dropped the ball there - mm-hmm
did they say that you're a fraud that
you'd assault ëcoz Faber wasn't there he
said nope no halo look you can say what
you want I probably have more halo than
80% of the people in this trailer
disagree with you here attact I actually
really liked the halo infinite trailer I
didn't like I just felt like they could
have did way more well that's like the
theme for Microsoft's conferences they
could have done way more but they didn't
I I don't know it wasn't expecting
gameplay for Halo infinite from the halo
5 aspect okay they force market again
bring that up from e3 perspective they
showed that wack you know desert thing
that didn't even show up in the game
yeah like two years later they showed
slice a little bit more than they showed
gameplay light but the guy didn't come
out for three years like the games
coming up next year there's no reason I
know I know for a fact 343 has gameplay
there's no way they don't there's they
had gameplay they just chose not to use
it they chose not to use a waist line 3
they chose not to use that just annoys
me it's like you could say what you
wanted by square and their final fantasy
80% day everything was gameplay just I
believe they got a whole game square but
they chose the conversation table was a
good conference but all they had to do
was do it in a different way to present
the information to you in a better way
and it would have been way better just
stairs alone I think the biggest thing
that they dropped the ball on you know
the halo thing that's mean that picking
because I'm a huge hanging offense I
wanted more that's me as a fan gears I
saw the most the most upset about if
they would have just got gears right
Ivan feeling the whole conference would
have been way different than just that
one thing just you know took take that
take that little bed little deer game
and put it on the road don't even show
that like wrenched Oh double oh seven
xbox instead of jump in their tag
ladders they could have done this
company I'm tired of it like they could
I'm tired of people have been having
that the resources to shut people off
and they don't do it literally when you
literally change your score pedido a
c-plus no I said that I was too harsh on
it at first
right because but Lizzie I was in the
moment people are defending it no it's
not defending I said initially my raw
reactions was too much okay it's just
like this he said there's no fate boys
definitely my feelings about that all
right but if you look at the the
conference on paper you can't say that's
like a deer and a half I'm sure if you
want to look down oh 14 x-box game
studios games city your or make you
upset over the conference i'm talking
about looking at the conference from a
perspective that has nothing to do with
that like before that moat night times
out of 10 people that watch I had no
idea Phil even know what's on at like we
getting hot in here is buddy get hot
it's like I said I would have preferred
more gameplay that's all I wanted like
you know you do that little initial
trailer you know can't go all crazy I
don't know what that was about then you
show about three or four minutes a game
play or a campaign then you show that
that lets xscape thing it was and then
you move on then you show wasteland game
page to three minutes like just little
things like that could have brought it
up a whole letter be some damp a you
know really quickly I just want to say
yeah I was down on it but I want to say
game pass
is amazing Oh like yeah game pass
ultimate is such a great deal I love how
Microsoft is premiering a lot of games
in game pass I love that gears ultimate
included in the ultimate subscriptions
you could play it early so I mean there
are things that that Microsoft you know
that we can talk positive I think the
new elite controller looks badass
it's like fixed everything's not are
good things and you know like hey at
least what I want to hear King man and
what he I don't know cuz I watched I
watched kognito and I lots sovereign and
I watched attic there video that day and
they were so disappointed they couldn't
believe it honestly don't know what King
thinks I need to know I said go ahead no
it's like I said that the reason I took
it from a detour to see it's just I do
feel like that baby would not be in
there affected me that day cuz I was
like cuz you could ask them like about
80% there I was like dude a favor went
here I don't even know if Abel's enough
to say this conference like I said that
but like I mean over there for foot her
dead dad wax show saved your whole
conference
crap you're getting they're gonna drip
dry you about and you good with all of
that and you're just gonna give you they
show want me to play a baby simulator
yeah yeah yeah you salty father reasons
but imma get in today I'm yeah what am i
salty but I'm get into this no you're
gonna have to explain why I'm talk to
you can't make things like that in the
walk away Oh see you
you just thinkin sweetness that you
can't back up listen to you fraud that's
why we need a fraud light because you
open the bag a little bit and I just
don't want to be mean the day a good for
the record we're stuck and you're
staying at C yes King sovereign thank
you for letting me switch up order
because red is right I know people been
dying we did our did our own issue of me
you and addict dinner initial
impressions outside of the comments
immediately after raw reaction King was
not present around yeah shout out to JD
gamer with the ten dollar super chat I'm
sorry
but some people that are dodging they
were saying it was will have a different
opinion sitting in my seat you know um
shout out to just first and foremost um
for being right there and you know we
looked at it and I gave him my answer my
answer still stands for the conference
now I'm gonna start off with this my
answer for the conference is it's a B
imma do it in different order other than
the other guys right it's a beat okay
now um Emma yeah in my heart I wanted
him to go for the jugular man I wanted
him to be filled ominous when I had them
t-shirt um I gave it to him
half-heartedly mmm alright because um
yeah greenie was lord greenie greenie
did his job right so what I want to feel
to be I want to feel to be Phil dumbest
that he dominate no he's feel political
mmm I thought and I'm not privy to a lot
of things I know was it was some deaths
this weekend
shout out to Amazon killing a game
division happy we saw X cloud a shout
out to that of Project X cloud coming to
all you guys that pre-order just stuff
for stadium shout out to the finish line
is in question because in October when
I'm gonna stuff it's a day y'all go see
now this is the reason why they have to
get a be alright because like you guys
are saying they didn't show what they
could I thought it last year when they
showed so much they got into that whole
chasing the bigger better how many
number things you know I'm 14 games 60
new on our platform
bro-bro scale it back back scale it back
showed up 14 and a proper light show
your stuff for real alright I'll be a
little bit clearer on a fact that I D at
Xbox is a side game pass be a little bit
clearer that if you have an existing X
Game pass that uh when you upgrade to
ultimate your whole game pass switches
to ultimate all the way up not that's
that one month that you paid for new bit
clearer and your messaging when you come
to the single-player campaign and Gears
of War be a little bit clearer when
you're going to your DLC that this is a
DLC segment and it shouldn't be shown on
the floor be Clara and give messaging we
I constantly was upset with these dudes
when they message wasn't clear a little
bit convoluted because you guys just
kept trying to give us so much and it
was so little information
good point Jess says that yeah just kind
of alluded to that all right you get you
gave me a lot of sizzle but not enough
taste Gianna read this cute offstage
you're talking point if people are
walking away and that is your highlight
Keano silhouette then brother you fail a
king it was breathtaking
he was breathtaking no I don't care Oh
all right it was a nice moment it was a
nice something for me to send out to
somebody it was a nice tweet for
somebody that wasn't sitting 10 feet
away from the man that was cute I've
been purchased to get up on stage and
the Telus stuff that you did I wanted
more battletoads
and it's amazing it's incredible well
why do I gotta give you after the
conference conference yeah good point I
don't need and I don't need to sit there
talking about make your little memes
like Jada know you know saying yo I see
you can't you write did he doing it you
didn't do it you can't became political
you should point out that King made
ex-client look better than Microsoft
made next class
IGN made escape from gears look better
than Microsoft made escape for Gears
wait next year how many next years I
gotta wait let me ask you this King be
based on your raw emotion how you feel
I'm not correlating this to be give it a
B no no no not even that I say I'm
eliminating favor because if you wanna
give me the whole power give you the
whole package the whole package they're
gonna be a plus all right if I'm giving
you just what we're asking about which
is this conference you didn't show back
up on stage was something up hmm
you pushed you ate
Oh hold on supporter right quick real
quick that second file on super track
gears 5 no gameplay 60 or game pass
final finding c7 $200 plus 50% of a game
but it has gameplay so hoots finesse and
who shout-out to EXO 19 in London I'm
there dead that's [ __ ] for beard up a
replica tell you good I'm saying this
right
it wasn't defending you left the dope
yes you know how you slam you want to
kill that monster video make sure you
put two on the head you want to chest
yeah and they tell you make sure that
monster did curbs bomb get them out of
it know you can give little catch
phrases we kill monsters I see I can
tell you stuff that went on in the back
at fan fest but if stage don't
reverberate so you became political in
the back he was Dominus but this is what
I'm saying here so I know next year you
gotta come with that little swag and do
your little thing um listen man I'm the
one sitting on the front line eating
this salt all right
I'm the one that's inside my DMS and
inside Twitter fighting these battles
that she started mmm you started battles
then I gotta sit here and tell these
people that yeah exile is real but had
you just pull somebody out the crowd in
defense to bill and they were they were
very concerned about how that would
happen and here's the point that bill
said and I'm not if it goes wrong you
only got one shot you know we have
trepidation on streaming and thinking
it's fraud arre so if they botch that
okay I had to pull that car back sigh
this reminds me of when they first
showed they first showed off the first
surface yes and it crashed
yes live demo I can't that killed
service for longer life run until the
surface three they really started taking
off again listen listen all this is my
baggage
yeah you understand all this even before
the shows like keep you expectations
here expectations that was likely to go
up there 130 coal each would sound like
a coach how's it go
I looked over at coolies what I said is
about to happen
to come crashing down in such a manner
it is not like yeah I felt the same
waking I really tell me tell me your
true feelings
the second that montage started at the
end because you knew it was over soon as
they go on tonight listen I didn't I did
nobody did did you know everybody there
was like he's like bro King let's keep
it 1000 when we all thought I'd always
know more and did the lights came on and
just we sat there frozen for second we
saw seeing people falling it was dead
silent I said like I said I said to Rand
on our last show we did run I said I
said things like or the show before I
think maybe I was talking about how
Microsoft at the corporate level they
struggle they still struggle with the
human element yes and they rely on day
Aaron's formulas and stuff like that and
I think ultimately the comments felt
formulaic yes and it felt like
they were you know just sort of they did
it's like someone said on paper this
looks really good but the feel was was
wrong and it's only after it was only
after the show and I got to speak to the
producers and I got to speak to Gears of
War and I got to speak to Mike I've
dungeons but it you know it made me feel
more positive about the whole thing
like after I after I left III and I
honestly felt like this might be my
favorite
III ever mmm so much to look forward to
like I really love my hunch and the full
blame LEDs really cool I thought I
thought I got a massive preview
minecraft on just coming out early this
week but I'll just say briefly like
Minecraft dungeons what they've done
with that game is really nail the feel
and I up low because like I'm a big
table fan on xbox and like I've always
felt path of Exile on Xbox he's now in
there as good as it is on PC like the
controls are janky and the inventory
management is a pain in path of Exile
and you got Warhammer Karis playing as
well which is pretty good but it still
feels a little bit janky so nothing's
really filled a babbler three void until
I played minecraft dungeons I was I'm
one of the only people who played at the
show because they won't actually give
him press demos I just know he's just
sitting right next to the guy and said
do you want to go
oh no yeah give me the before let me go
for three minutes I wouldn't let any
other journalists play fit I gotta ask
Jess imranís and King touched on some
points right and I guess I want to dive
deep in me and saw I've had this
discussion so I know you up next I just
I just don't want to forget this why do
you think their mindset why is Marcus
old why do you feel like they tend to
hold back right because the the
impression for a lot of Xbox fans there
is that like you said after the
conference is over we're getting this
plethora of information that sounds
fantastic then you find out these games
are great and then you find out project
looks fantastic so far in the setting
that we played right and it's just like
but the masses don't know that right so
we're privy press is privy the hardcore
gamers content creators influences they
are privy but why do you think their
minds
is to not reveal that on stage I want to
go into Ramsbury but what do you think
is the thought process the to the way
they handle the presentation of their
conferences I you know I was thinking
that as well I'm not really sure but I
think there's some a lot of still
trepidation around what happened to
scalebound and fable legends and
eventually what they promised and what
we ended up with with crackdown 3 mm-hmm
I still think there's some lingering
effects of that like should we show
fable now you know like should we hold
it for next year should we tease what
initiatives do it like they have look I
still 100% believe and we're actually
the next box is going just because they
have a bad press conference yeah doesn't
mean that I'm on
I hate xbox whatever let's just shout
out the adderall just because I didn't
enjoy the show doesn't mean like
suddenly you know I'm going to start
making Xbox hate videos it's just one
show at the end of the day what is it
really matter who it's like I didn't
like it I'll move on I'll get over it
it's not that big of a thing I just
didn't enjoy the presentation I thought
they could have done a lot better but
the reason I'm excited is because I've
always just want the one thing I've
always wanted from Xbox is just more
games from them and better quality games
and you know that really hasn't been the
case they don't really have a big first
party stable of developers until now so
I'm like I'm looking like a Obsidian
what they're gonna do for you know outer
world so that after outer worlds and the
initiative like I don't know why people
think the initiatives games gonna be a
double a experience you see the people
the initiatives hiring like here's the
thing right I got it I got it I gotta
come at you a little bit you're right on
paper paper champions exactly and now
I'm concerned now I'm at the point where
I'm not believing anything until you're
sure I mean I'm not believing I'm just
saying I'm not gonna let a conference
yeah well I hate Xbox now it's over it's
done with I'm a hundred percent
PlayStation because that's not who I am
like is something
all right if Xbox users never even see
this conference most like I said I you
know I got friends and of who play xbox
and I'm like I'm at e3 this way you can
like what's e3 most normies don't even
know what it is you're right you're
right I don't think some of their stuff
is a little too kitty like I don't
really like Battletoads I don't like
that design you know whether or not it
plays good whatever but I still think it
looks too kitty I don't know like I
think it's like on paper it's like we
got 14 games from first-party we have 60
games total and it's like oh man that
sounds amazing but when do you like I
don't know about you guys but I thought
the conference started off on the wrong
foot I don't think outer worlds was the
best the best game to start it with and
it's like another game that that I
didn't absorb like I completely forgot
our world was even there so like a brand
I didn't absorb it and the trailer was
um basically like it was it was the
first game shown and then Ori to my game
with the game I was looking forward to
the most delayed all their games in my
pain already showed of me like the boss
fights cockney no dude it's the third
year we've seen a two-minute canary
trailer Ori this is why like the whole
like idea of like Phil doesn't like to
show games too early I was kind of scoff
at because hey what do you mean three
years three e3s for Ori to to eat all
three two minute trailers halos gonna be
a3e threes yeah by the time it comes out
like I think you just kind of said that
mainly because I didn't really have
anything to show period and then slice
go to be like what we don't like showing
stuff early know you kind of clearly do
sometimes when you actually have stuff
yeah that devastated me like I don't
know like the problem is like I'm
disappointed because I know they can do
better
mmm-hmm so you know that's my whole
thing let's kiss off I know each other a
bit soggy but patient solved you know
listen guys no more reactions I don't
think it's changed at all I gave it a
c-minus
after the video that we did and I think
that remains the same and it remains the
same specifically for something that I
mentioned before and maybe my thinking
in this regard is archaic I don't know
but for me III still is it's the Super
Bowl everybody's everybody's there
should be there right it is the one time
of the year when the eyes of all of
gaming are one singular thing right
because if you're a playstation head
you're not watching Microsoft stuff
other than at e3 right because that's
everything's all together the same thing
for Microsoft that give you night you're
not paying attention this where we
placed it yourself still close the bills
no doubt no doubt
um JD gamer thank you brother $20 super
chair Mike microsomes playing a high
state game of chicken with Sony and
that's why they're holding back their
big guns
then the jugular next year and that is
part of the problem they need to
outmaneuver Sony with gains and power
okay Wow Dalila HD with the first battle
tools plays Welles but the art style
should go with the bushes look
aggressive at all - Tanja was
assassinated I was with her I told her
to you know definitely check it out and
I am going to agree with her as far as
they did didn't make them aggressive
because they're appealing you know they
don't have kid games mmm and they're
trying to crack that kid market yeah and
and yeah and that game actually talks to
children like talks to kids so yeah it's
not aggressive fuss
Dalila and that is 100% the truth that
is no lie and you know she's right there
and you know I can I can go exactly the
what she said is that is true but that
has not made it easier no it's not easy
as that at all Ori effect was so pretty
but
because I'm standing with the head guy
and shoutout for me for not remembering
names only know Nina Kristensen from
head of admin today I hope I didn't
butcher her last name um because you
know she made sure that I played
bleeding-edge um but when he was
planning we would you know touching the
game it was all hand drawn so it's just
all official is it has that film of a
cup hit type of feel without the film on
it but then when you got to the segment
of the the bike riding it's so
incredibly hard not to do I said you
know has anybody beat it so one guy Wow
one guy today and he said you know we
have a 95 percent failure rate and
people leave the gate I left the game
this I need to just get gameplay this is
no way no drum beat and my and his three
players at the same time and my two
teammates he looked at me they said you
don't say yes this MJ we all done
together because it was absolutely so
hard hopefully they got a casual move
for the finisher bags yes strong like
for me it's like it's the Super Bowl of
every sports analogy you can think of
when it comes to e3 it is in play right
to me this is the time to show not only
to excite your base but to maybe get
somebody who's not necessarily so
interested in your ecosystem to start
looking your way because that's another
thing why I think the big three are
always held to a higher standard is you
have the task in addition to getting
people to be excited about your games
you need to get people excited about
your ecosystem and I think they didn't
do that right they spoke to the choir
the people that they know I'm gonna be
there regardless but they didn't do
anything that I felt brought new people
in right during during our impressing
this video I said everything that I
solved the smaller games to Blair which
everything is going it's a game past day
one the smaller ID at Xbox all that
stuff looks great
Oh give me a montage of that I don't
need to see extended gameplay of that
mmm the fact you're not showing me Gears
5 campaign gameplay a game is coming out
in 3
it's spooky to me it does it it's it's
worrisome to me and I don't understand
this snare for me
III is the place where you go to drop
the mic and don't they didn't do that
yeah you understand yeah yeah exactly
and to me it just doesn't make any sense
B and you know speaking for just from
you know like a financial perspective
like if they still Chow ting this is
this the place to be the place to go for
all these announcements that what not do
spend thousands of dollars to get
thousands of dollars to get there and be
there for a week and experience the
stuff firsthand and to be safe I think
it's a slap in the face to you're amazed
that the gamers in general it's a
because at that point if that is the
case and III really has shift and it is
not that anymore right don't do it
anymore come right out come right out
and say a3 is not that anymore
Oh pull of Sony mm because you would
rather make sure that then whatever that
you got make sure they don't put that
out there just do a Sony take my money
not at all show up everything that I saw
I said it I'm gonna play the thing about
it is no hypocrite I'm saying example
I'm in line with everything I said
because I remember what you said after
the conference and I don't you said
today brother because everything I said
after the conference I'm holding it to I
said it's a beat hmm and they ain't
never changed it is never gonna change
now me being extended to all our other
stuff that's after that I have to close
all that off and give you exactly how I
felt right there in that moment all
right and I'm you know left at the altar
that's not a B though I'm giving you
confidence what is the reasoning as to
why we feel left at the altar okay well
one I thought he's gonna come back out
and say surprise
ham and cheese EU man
I had just hey for me it wasn't the
content shown because the client awesome
and the sheer amount of talent and skill
the ninja theories pointing out and I
feel like a lot of some of the some of
the you know the talking heads out there
assigned the conference talk through
really what they're attacking is the
games and they're salty that there's no
Last of Us you know and so to the Last
of Us but and I think that's really
unfair because like a bleeding edge is
made by a team of 20 people yes
and that's that's an incredible feat
minecraft options is made by a team of
20 people and that's incredible feat and
these are Intel in credibly intelligent
passionate creative smart people back do
way more incredible things with their
time than some [ __ ] commenting on and
I and I completely agree with that yes
yeah you have those games those bigger
games right if you do have them in tow
mmm-hmm why is this not the stage to say
hey we're doing this well yeah I mean
great the whole criticism for me bows
down to that sort of stuff it falls on
the people who decided this was the show
it was gonna get and also for those
smaller games those scrappy games
leading edge and minecraft dungeons
which are being made by smaller teams it
falls on these bigger games to bring
people into the ecosystem who then might
try the smaller games and that's you as
are you coming to Microsoft ecosystem
for Minecraft dungeons right is that
gonna convert you to a micro person or I
actually expect minecraft dungeons to
sell my drive is also on every platform
known to man its poor and it's on switch
and it's on PC minecraft dungeon is
gonna be truly huge but you know that's
beside the point
like the the point is ultimately that
it's it's supposed to be these heavy
hitters that bring people into the
ecosystem and Microsoft's always saying
like in the new Xbox app on Windows 10
there's a big button which basically
says which what game will you play next
and you hit it and it gives you a random
game pass game the whole point of gaming
had that they were pushing is they try
games you might not have otherwise tried
right needs those headlines
how Hollywood blockbusters to bring
people over to try these and that you've
never heard of like no Norma he's gonna
have heard of leading-edge and they're
probably never I think that's the
problem they failed the moment to mean
that's it guys x-factor that was really
yeah hold on one second face 23 BK New
York with the $2 super chat thoughts on
inside is here in PlayStation 5 is more
powerful we actually talked about that
earlier in reference to the the rumors
that we heard so you know it's still up
in the air man we still got to figure
out solve continue and then you're great
and then I'll get into it no that's it i
think i said it's a c-minus the same as
i gave it right after the conference
yeah because again the content is it's
all stuff that I obviously want to play
and I'm interested in I'm super
interested in that Blair Witch game
because I thought it was either Alan
Wake or Silent Hill but yeah I love this
for a minute and twelve minutes was
another one instead like everything I
love most about the conference was what
I saw afterwards yes yes what I learned
afterwards what I learned after yeah let
me jump it yeah killing this man this is
a great this is great this is one of
these the weirdest situations because
obviously you know you saw the video me
saw a fanatic put out and right after
raw reactions and Kings making good
points to jazz of course ran on fire I
think it's like the reality of the show
when you take a step back and you look
at it on paper yes it's not a bad show
on paper right to me the reality a
tangible reality of X cloud game pass
ultimate the services and cyberpunk on
this dais yes outstanding cyberpunk is
my game with a generation I definitely
loved that you know again it's not
terrible but in reference to their own
IPs and the way they were presented it
was extremely lackluster it was very
pedestrian to me they spent more effort
showcasing cyberpunk
which is not their own IP better than
their own IPs like a gear so during the
Scarlet thing I'm with ran like I rolled
my eyes because my thing is this it felt
like a straight rehash of the X rollout
right and the way I'm saying is I have
to look at this selfishly as a hardcore
gamer right as a hardcore Xbox game
my console of preference right this show
didn't appeal to me now for the masses
that may not you know they may not all
make this show for the games they it for
them it's great you know that but to me
I felt it was say me you know say it was
safe it was say me with the extra bill
and you can't get the bass excited if
you're not showing certain original IP
so at least giving people hope for the
future it's hard to say hey we're coming
out with a new console ready to flex a
little money down it doesn't like yeah
that's a hard sell
I had this conversation where Jackson in
the DM you know so I'm about to get
killed for this next one but hey lo if
they didn't do not for me ran it fell
vertical it felt very verticals it
graphically I was it I wasn't wow they
look better this you know say like and
then I'm like the continuity chief
floating in space I'm like where is this
in the halo 5 I remember another
conversation they're meeting mostly
whatever like where is this so again I'm
getting shades of mass chief with the
concho when they showed that one and
then the game came out and that wasn't
there and again for those who were there
let me be completely on in that
conference before that conference
started jazz King solve the place was
fever pitch dissipation hi people
weren't ready for Xbox to show out there
like Sony's not here we got they gonna
show out you don't say at least get
people hi you know and like King said
behind the scenes they're talking strong
talk be strong oh they got the chest now
it's and then when it started I was
saying right up into the point
cyberpunk the roof blew up that place
erupted I'm not gonna lie the emotional
weight of that it looked great
you had him the breathtaking moment that
was the high point at that point it was
Bambi in the deer games and this isn't
real of a whole bunch of Indies that
they probably spent a little bit too
much time well you know gears with the
connection face a que no gameplay and
then and then it just and I'm like okay
you know I'm looking at attic I'm like
okay you know they they probably holding
on you know I'm saying the service is a
great but it's just at the end it just
felt
to me and I felt it was just an
opportunity missed it didn't speak to
the harp or game to the casual gamer who
looks at it yo I was impressed I saw a
lot of games that shows for you no
disrespect I'm just worried as the
hardcore Xbox game is this how it's
going to be for for now on is this the
new norm where they're not speaking to
me I'm nervous for that brand I'll be
honest you know I'm just concerned
because I look at a Nintendo show and
they do these little noises for their
hardcore base that only their hardcore
base would appreciate or even if they do
something wrong they say hey like if
they would have got me and I'd had this
conversation if they would have got out
in front of the fable thing and say look
ya'll yeah Abell rumblings keep that in
check it's not gonna be there so much
but you've got a guy like a D you got
all these people saying y'all fable
might get there you know you've got to
get in front of that stuff yeah but by
saying fables not gonna be there you
basically confirm that it exists
Microsoft want to confirm that exist
though so but I think one of to me
saying like that there's a human element
missing air box pure operation is vast
it is vast and it permeates the whole
company they don't have a separate PR
arm for Xbox and Windows and and their
enterprise stuff it oughta khals through
the same system and I'm wondering if
like some aspects of that machine are
still sort of stuck in the past
yes yeah you know you're not gonna
promote your enterprise stuff the same
way you would bring entertainment stuff
right all the time Xbox has been pulling
away from Microsoft in general what we
finally have a store up for PC games on
it Windows this is actually cool right
and the Xbox team made that themselves
and they basically said f you to the
windows team do it ourselves cuz you
guys can't do it for whatever reason and
I feel like gradually over time Xbox is
sort of establishing itself as a
separate entity within Mark stuff but I
still feel like there is still some of
that old one sense yes he is the point
it's just like you know what what's
frustrating about I had this
conversation with soft jazz this what's
frustrating about it it's not like but
like us we're privy to
information right so it's not like
they're lying right it's not like
they're they didn't show because they're
really being deceptive right or they
don't have nothing here all right
God's no there's no real well it's it's
just it's just naive et a little bit
yeah it's like I even talked to shot the
bill again with the project I'm like man
if there was some way people could see
and you know it just you guys have great
tech great ideas great games we know
they're working on stuff we know it I
mean like this is not Xbox bash fest we
know it's just it seems to be a
conscious decision and I think ran is on
something it almost feels like a secret
memo went out said look after scale bear
we got never showing anything you know
if it's not six month whatever but then
they sit there and then do the gears
thing and I'm like what the hell's going
that's the scary thing is like because
it's so close to launch she feels that
feels deceptive ah you know the Scarlet
thing though it seems like they did it
like that because it worked for the ex
yes I'm not repeat it it's like we're
gonna do the same exact thing down to
the letter forming in the video come on
say it's a monster monsters for
breakfast I would like in my preview
video I'm like they're gonna do a high
peace I didn't think they'd literally do
the exact same video with you know
talking heads up there being like a
capability fast loading in an SSD
hardware Rachel it was like literally
the same years ago but ran don't you
need that you know ray-tracing hardware
the cues don't you need that fast SSD
don't you mean they're not faster
because those words is being spoken in
the other camp that didn't show up sure
you a hundred percent I'm just saying
I'm just saying I would have liked a
little bit more originality
just copying your homework from three
years previous tell me about this it
just felt like when I can predict
exactly what you're going to do
good luck I'm a nobody I don't have a I
don't have a business degree I don't
have marketing degree and I knew exactly
what Microsoft was gonna do on that
front and then to see like oh the
letters are forming again I'm like well
again we would see we were shocked by it
when I started seeing I looked over
Cognito and I like really no man no and
it was like the same panning of the
camera the same no this can't be
I'll tell you something inside arisha
bad about those videos but the style of
the way those videos are shot they do
that for things that they're showing
developers behind closed scenes - I've
seen you guys have seen two of those
videos with the gray background I've
seen dozens of like it's not it's not
just for like these code names it's
stuff like they've done one like this
for dx12 a bunch of a bunch of guys like
like the really boring dev stuff that
goes over our heads this is just the
style of video they use so like I think
for them it's not they're not thinking
of it in terms of we want this video to
build high for the console this is like
this is like basically a a high budget
PowerPoint presentation yes
they send though those style of videos
they send them ads for other things so I
do think it was like I agree with Rand
that it was a mistake for them to
present it that way in exactly the same
way that it last time and it shows like
a lack of imagination but at the same
time I also think like they they
probably had that video done months ago
and that probably showed there might
have even shown off at GDC behind closed
doors and stuff and they probably just
thought like instead of spending the
time and money to do like a sizzle reel
this year we'll just use a frame teaser
and then we'll go in for the the high
production value surface like advert
next year you know oh I guess here's my
thing I want to double down what you say
is that I always feel presentation just
seems to be that Achilles heel right
consistent it's
gets to a point where it's like okay
what is the reasoning why why does this
happen because clearly the Hardcore are
saying is we you know we're saying hey
man this just wasn't presented right it
wasn't presented right so it's just
wondering you know is it a situation
I've had a theory again I could be
completely wrong I don't know this I'm
putting it for the record it almost
feels like again Phil they have his
vision right of what he wants doing how
he wants to present it but it almost
feels like there's something conflicting
with I don't want to say marketing or
whoever's in charge of present
presenting right I mean I don't know if
that still all the way either but I just
it just feels like there's a disconnect
and you know the hardcores like we want
this and they're like no we give you
this in this way it's gonna stay
you know saying and it there's no
attempt to bridge like what do you guys
feel about that again this falls this
falls on like wider pervasive marks of
corporate problems but it's just this
sort of huge huge vast machine with so
many cogs and working different working
parts and sort of trying the sort of
consistency across their marketing their
branding like even little things like
they've got like five different styles
of context menu like hey they don't have
a centralized authority aesthetics like
like Apple does like apples presentation
and the way they pretend things is
always fun they've been selling the same
iPhone for ten years and no one seems to
care you know and that's partly because
they're they're amazing consistency and
that sort of thing Microsoft sort of
they they like they do need something to
improve aspects of their delivery
mm-hmm you know it's it's a massive
company on that company yeah that's a
good point you put it in perspective and
I know I'm running on and it's going
long but JD gaming with this ten hours
of a chat Microsoft will never reach to
two billion gamers without making their
core gamers their first fans happy we
are the cheerleaders and the casuals
come through us stop looking at
spreadsheets and pay attention records
oh man I mean that's what I got its
overall I still stayed consistent at a/c
let's wrap up and do our rankings
overall with the conference's real quick
Lester
way to start without Lorraine as far as
the order who won I mean it pains me the
same intending on fire right now I don't
care about Nintendo but I will admit
they had a good show all the other ones
are basically all the same Square Enix
Bethesda Microsoft's they're all in that
same range and I I'm sorry
I need gameplay demos III don't care
about two-minute quick cut trailers they
do nothing for me or CGI stuff so yeah
that's my kind of thoughts on all this
Oh Lord
guess who won e3 well you know because I
haven't seen all the conference's no but
I mean again it's like I'm kind of
biased towards Microsoft but only
because I saw the stuff come afterwards
you know I think then but then it
Nintendo's the opposite way just like in
turn I had a really good show but then
details come out after like oh like
Animal Crossing one of cloud say like
it's like the opposite like Nintendo 3d
pipe and then afterwards the high was
like my like nowhere to be seen and then
afterwards I sort of guide so I'm gonna
say it's it's a draw between the you got
a jug alright so basically like yourself
rose up after recoveries and there's a
rose that'd a bet develop fear I swear
if I cut if I can't get like my ally cuz
I'm in a respect for man I respect that
Lord solve overall who won III is like
he's not gonna say the same thing as me
you can't as him or you who
[Applause]
anytime Nintendo's in the building you
were compromised are the journalists me
I give it to the Microsoft and then I
guess Square Enix and uh and the rest
and EA is definitely in the bushes I
said is this boss everyone's in the
bushes you learned is a big that's the
Reg you feel yourself yes sir
all right Lord King who won III should I
be surprised okay you see the reason why
is boys jazz definitely highlighted the
folks with both companies
first of all let's shout out for who's
in the bushes all those dudes that don't
make hardware get out of here all right
we not even gonna talk to you guys and
no but Thursday y'all want to try to act
like I'm a hard worker survivors they
get all right so now there's only two
people because the other person got a
straight F you failed you failed to live
up to the expectations of your fans you
fail to live up to the expectations of
the people in your company you fail to
live up to the expectations of people
who thought that you would do something
this week and any remote wait you know
for those people those knees is in this
infinity gonna box you know how that
does the fill box with the knees in it
because a lot of people said oh don't
worry
you know Sony's gonna show up in some
form of capacity they didn't show up at
all you got your money
no laughs eight like that was what was
rumoured to this is this is what you do
right I want you to go down to
McDonald's I want you to stick your $20
in the window and walk away because you
got served nothing you put your money up
you got nothing all right
now did show up it was a good talk about
a conference you choose you get a - I
gotta - out as far as content I love the
content on Nintendo's show it was great
peace and it was a good thing it was
better than last year and you guys
definitely did not come out on top so
I'm gonna fire you my fan boy is gonna
roll there's no point
you already got two frauds here there's
no rock with you you don't need me to
rock with petroleum a text cloud I'm
rocking with all that stuff I'm walking
with that game press
I've been purchase I told you read one I
was compromised but Nintendo do not win
sir
oh yes with these two dudes in the
bushes did not do you having drinks I
got your back go listen I got attend no
I mean in order real quick but there's
the to Microsoft f3 you we saw square
and then PC gaming and then Sony with
the f4 incomplete for not coming and
then I'll just do something real quick
we'll get out of here I'm just doing my
top three games of e3 which will be on
obviously the legendary cyberpunk I
don't know what type of magic they work
and I'm super excited that's gonna be my
game of the gen Jedi fallen order was
the only thing worth even checking out
EA about and man respawn is on it they
showing the versatility as a dev
single-player I'm super hyper all
running like titanfall and I'm all the
way in watchdogs Legion like ran said
super high
I know people hating on goes for wire
Tokyo but that's like a little time for
me I'm talking about the concept and the
last thing I want to shout out a little
indie dev studio that was one of
Microsoft's my honorable mentions called
unto the Inc it's made by two person
team husband and wife they got I've
heard about this game
two years in development 2017 they made
it shout out the big sugar they were on
the idea at Xbox stage I was very proud
to see them check them out you hear more
about that game coming if you're a fan
of like inside if you're a fan of alone
in another world you know I'm saying
it's like picture that and picture
torment from Game of Thrones running
around in that world
truth the atmosphere is outstanding yo
so that's my joint I don't know if
anybody had any game when it shows they
want to get in there before we get out
oh I want it like I've already told you
about solid fungal minecraft on there's
a lot but I really want to shout out
stuff
Romero games and Paradox Interactive old
Empire of sin yeah I got to say behind
closed doors right XCOM meets Grand
Theft Auto meets muff like like like
yeah like mafia meets ear it's crazy so
just really quickly
you can select loads of classic
gangsters like Al Capone and stuff like
that and it's same like 1920s Chicago I
think during the premiere you basically
you come into the city and then it's
your job to build up a criminal empire
so you go around whacking other
gangsters ham rackets and all the combat
is turn-based the grid base like
wasteland and XCOM and then you have to
manage your money flow and and all of
the violence is spectacular that is
coming to everything it's gonna use AI
station xbox pc and um and stadia i
guess but it looks really really really
blew my mind like I really like strategy
games I really like like I rely Grand
Theft Auto and this American mines all
of them so Wow that's your honorable
mention that's a shout-out for that one
of the shows probably right between
minecraft dungeon 2077 but also our
shadow dying light too as well we like
radar
honestly I went from Simon from 2077
straight to don't like to I will say no
I'd like to look more polished and
hmm like the awesome gameplay like those
guys have way more experience with
first-person and CD Projekt RED and you
can tell ya I really believe that
cyberpunks coming out in April though I
think so I believe I'm expecting a delay
for that game don't sleep on down like -
yeah they'll see one now like yo real
quick just before I did you get the
chance to see John with hex I missed
that one okay I just want to know if
anybody saw it XL - all right on any
standouts ran for you always pay the
bills game about choice thank you
brother
$10 super Chad thank you for keeping it
real in this podcast this III left me
saying it was okay but I cannot wait
till next III you all are awesome thank
you so much appreciate the support
big-time
watchdogs Legion thank you for the
gameplay Ubisoft appreciate it shoutout
xbox game pass ultimate incredible deal
yeah you can get all that stuff one of
the maybe the best thing in gaming going
on right now in the best best thing is
Phil hinting that X cloud yeah I I
hundred percent we're gonna pretend
expect X cloud to be included in either
game pass or game pass ultimate yeah
that's it I know we're approaching the
three-hour mark
Lola 200 likes people like slow down arm
saw of King your standouts and let's get
him breathing edge again yeah cuz that's
a whole lot of game for by a small team
I just like the fact that they were all
there we just talked to Ronnie Tucker
they were all playing with you this is
such passion is such love they were so
excited to have their game finally be
announced on the stage like it that is
what I love most about e3 and you know
that's what I love most about pax right
I thought it would be a different
experience and for the most part it is
but when you do have those those moments
when you can talk to the devs and a game
is shown on the biggest stage ever
there's nothing quite like it man so big
shout out to them and beyond
Ultimate Alliance man I'm excited for
you it's looking good
cogs footage got me yummy amped camera
let's go yes go go down Lord King stand
out to the show shout outs we cracked
that hundred that's one sort of thing
and all the super charts and all that
stuff um my standouts boy the remnant
that game is a randomly generated world
and the game looks fantastic she's using
Unreal Engine and got a chance to talk
with the dev there and the PR department
um I got more stuff coming
you got one video that was the fan fest
video you're gonna have the Bethesda
video and you're gonna have the video
that's coming next
um but Battletoads I know for some
people is not for you for me it is
because I'm gonna sit there with my kids
and I'm gonna play and it's like a
cartoon just come to life it's beautiful
Oh
Darksiders Genesis mmm that formula C
because I don't know I was waiting for
Darksiders I was just getting a purchase
Darksiders today just to get that story
out the way Darksiders 3 just to gear up
for this Genesis I got a chance to play
a strife um and then you switch to war
and and war feels like war our game is
so beautiful I love the art direction
tht Nordic is so fantastic I loved them
as a developer and they put out such
great stuff like at battle chases that
wasn't talked about enough before and
I'm you know just booted it up and I
said I'm gonna get ready I wanted to get
off this show to play it's I think th
Hugh Nordic is on that wave and if y'all
haven't you know checked out a lot of
this stuff go check out this stuff now
and get ready for the dark side is um
the Genesis because it looks like it's
gonna continue in the next path of great
Darkseid of games no doubt and that
concludes the e3 2019 recap aftermath
series Lord jazz
Lord Ram
an absolute pleasure to finally have you
both back I know we had some technical
difficulties and we missed you guys for
the Xbox my for your podcast I have my
hat you see I say go out wait for y'all
did happen but I'm glad we is able to
link on this one so let's start off with
Lord jazz where can I find people find
you what do you have cooking on windows
central.com so excited well you can find
me you know windows central.com
well most on twitter @jj is it seaworthy
and next week I'm gonna tell you angle
this what I've got here right now we
draft it whatever I have a post III
write up on what I think Microsoft's
messaging is on the conference so I prom
2077 huge preview as about the story and
stuff like that
minecraft dungeons everything you need
to know just a bullet point list of
everything every question I've got with
an answer also a gameplay impression
this gives will 5 interview game earth
gameplay oppressions mmm edge gameplay
impressions and interview is what ice
boy impressions I like to impressions
our impressions and planetfall
impressions which is a unit sieve like
game for Xbox so heat cover bed I can't
wait with loved your project gets cloud
stuff and actually you you dropped a gem
about that you said Age of Empires is
becoming a Microsoft studio now last
night can you have Broadway real quick
yes so basically this is kind of teased
this a few months ago I'd heard
Microsoft was looking at taking its much
its Age of Empires operation more
seriously and they like the work that
their relic and they are basically
spinning up a new studio or well it sort
of existed but it didn't have a name and
it didn't sort of like it was sort of
like a technical support studio before
just a sort of work on Age of Empires
definitive edition the first one but now
they're gonna spin up and hopefully
they'll be sitting alongside three for
three and then playground mmm RTS
Studios there hopefully as Legionnaire I
believe and you got people you you got
you got Microsoft westerns they're like
Adam high screens
and you're gone so it's it's less
serious about it so wow that's cool I
don't know that call yet the names
through their marketing department and
legal and stuff but I should have a name
like recent product probably announce it
when the next day the billion next big
in photo for age four whenever that
happened so nice
huge huge mega time I appreciate the
outstanding reporting Lord Ram glad to
have you back in good health and back in
the room sir what do you have couldn't
get a fantastic video of actually
yesterday reference to the whole
Lockhart thing that was great what else
do you got cooking all looking fine who
finds you um yeah thanks I mean I wish I
could have been here for the you know
the the Mafia thought yeah well means
that Google didn't want the show that we
got that great meme though of you uh
going uh like I forget what it's like
you like screaming or yeah I love coming
on ILP but yeah if you you know you want
to check out my stuff it's Randall 499
on YouTube appreciate you guys having me
appreciate King telling the truth you
know I knew he would everybody's
opinions some like some might get some
don't don't twist your panties over it
whatever
nobody's flip-flop it and nobody's like
hate maxbox now it's like I do like show
here's the thing I don't care about
PlayStation I don't like I care about
Xbox so maybe I grade them a little bit
harsher than I normally would when you
does it's like I see potential
I see what you could be try to grab that
brass ring next time I know you can do
much better no doubt respect that lower
rant on it's always informative keeping
us abreast super respected Lord
solve what could if I'm people find you
I'm standing reporting sir yes I'm very
worried
big shout out to ran it just for coming
through really appreciate it
and you catch me on a Twitter loss of
IOP be excited on PSN and Xbox Live and
definitely check out our videos from e3
on iron Lords pocket
at YouTube video interview with Ronnie
Tucker from edge it's great and and our
raw reaction video some poster press
conferences so please check that stuff
out more coming Lord King the premium
xbox III gamer vomit out here dropping
bombs everybody wanted to hear your
impression kept it as 100 as he can do
didn't have one what have I always said
when you deal with King you know
look at the pink from be is like a see
from anybody else first and foremost I
would love to say uh thank you just for
showing up I met you and I was like man
when I finally meet the guy to it would
actually was three guys and he's like
yeah I'm sending them out to do things
it was like yes yes bring me back
information to be to just feels bad all
of its like a 33 I gotta be just there
are so many people I have one each man I
really wanted to meet Delilah and I just
I can make a wrong turn stuff like
that's just the nature of III could tell
you kick yes and I'm one of me brand I
drink with the man like 9 yes no King I
don't drink but I'll have a drink with
listen give you the finest social water
finest ginger ale ginger ale you have a
I don't drink but I will I'll make an
exception with you I'll graph I'll get
in a Long Island iced tea hey drew
driver or something so hopefully next
year we flew it yeah because you know
like I always tell people and I'm not
gonna be a
brought on this there's three people
that I aspire to get my videos to their
quality and if it doesn't meet their
standards if it doesn't mean rands cold
the dealer standards it doesn't meet my
standards and um I'm telling you these
are the guys I look for when I go online
at all times
um that's not gonna change because I
love what they all bring to the table
unique stuff so when you said adjust
video I was like yeah I watched that one
and I shut myself off from everything
III just to consume each conference in
its entirety while I was there you know
um so the team I'm so pleased with the
team from sinister to monkey to go
supreme to lord kognito the sovereign to
to to boom it was it was a cohesive unit
that was moving as one we was all over
the tentacles was all over California
and some people was moving 110 miles an
hour some people moving five miles an
hour but everybody was moving you know
and it's a ton of content that you will
get that you will see and it's
everybody's different perspective on
what they saw how they felt and we may
not always agree and that's why you're
tuned in because we may not Dayton
that's how it is but we do respect it
and I and I did say hypocrite I meant to
call him a fraud um that that word was
too big it was wrong all right no no you
know I just had to clear it up on there
because I'm not gonna clear it up in
your DM and I'm gonna clear it up on a
Funko I'm gonna clear up I was just
calling him a fraud the H word here
listen man they they know and in my
heart that I for me to say Nintendo was
out there swingin them bats there was
knocking people upside their heads so it
was it was a great thing man
and do appreciate everybody that showed
up absolutely a fantastic fantastic
panel again jazz ran always welcome in
the realm of the Lord so I want to shout
out Lords of gaminggod met Lord dizzy
Joshua Gondor on doing all the team MJ's
a boss old-school-style l-boogie stream
team P DS now though all of you guys
like just to work and uplifting us and
helping us out while we out there
running around was really tremendous man
Lord mods gaming I can I forget the
technical acumen just really killing it
for us on what's going on out here while
we work in tremendous additions we're
gonna have a lot of stuff coming king
he's got stuff cooking king of the
statues he's doing he's got a great G
what kognito made me do right yeah but
we love that fan fest video to give
people the premium view behind the scene
how it feels like to be like the King to
see what the king is experiencing shout
the fill I gotta call him Phil Diamond
expensive for throwing up the IOP dough
that was kind of hot King I gotta give
you that one yeah you know what he you
know they they called me up to talk loan
and he asked me right there he was like
so what do you think I'm not a looter
like no I'm not I said imma let you
basking in mom's gonna take a picture
with you do you think I said but you
know you don't want this for me I need
to tell you guys an embarrassing story
before we go let's go
well I ran randon you guys like you were
talking about ice iced tea right along
well I went I went like to a business
meeting business lunch right it was like
about 1:00 in the afternoon and um like
you know I was with Americans be an
American you know they were like they
all ordered iced tea now
maybe me British I have no idea why
steers I'm just automatically assumed
ice tea mint alcohol law galilei's
because like in where I come from we
don't buy some tea I thought no having
Long Island iced tea so when I ordered
my drink I was like I'll have a double
hug
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
salute everybody happy Father's Day
everybody enjoy your Sunday the Lord's
will return geez